une production du studio sf
bio venus au sans fil est représentée
par kay semi le podcast on parle aux
convecteurs invités date si tu cherches
quentin avec moins des 10 dom de pointe
et semi vous le savez il prendre la
diversité puis c'est pour ça que si
jamais vous allez sur leur site si vous
trouvez pas un qu'est-ce qui vous
représente comme vous aimez à être
représentés mais vous pouvez faire un 15
coste hommes avec les icônes et les
côtes que vous voulez et ont plus de 150
icônes que vous pouvez drag-and-drop sur
votre caisse pour favre dans le quinze
de l'iphone qui vous ressemble fait
qu'aller voir sur pu utiliser le code
promo sans filtre vente pour leur
montrer que si nous que vous envoie puis
aussi avoir 20% de rabais sur toutes vos
commandes fait que mercy qasmi cette
semaine dans cette semaine énorme
plaisir énorme chance de recevoir deux
athlètes olympiques fraîchement revenu
de tokyo katerine savard ie8 se fit
harvey qui ont performé qui en danger
aux olympiques catherine savoir si la
troisième participation mais il se fit
sa première
ont des bruits on parle de sport passe
de natation on parle de leur expérience
comme un conte des cuissons leur
préparation pour se rendre aux
olympiques c'est vraiment super
c'est vraiment le fun d'avoir ce que
cet accès la comprenons plus comment ça
se passe la vie aux olympiques la
préparation pour se rendre vraiment la
lgv la vie dans la foule est plus que ce
qu'on voit à la télévision vraiment un
autre qui l'est qui nous l'expliquent le
c'était vraiment un grand plaisir de
s'entretenir avec lui puis aussi surtout
je trouve le chemin pour se rendre là
parce que le chemin et tout le monde a
un chemin qui différent pis c'est le
chemin qui compte qu'il fallait c'est
pas le poids la médaille casquette a
déjà lu l'alchimie ch
et
le chemin aux
toute cette lan des histoires
incroyables qui content d'avoir on a
reconnu un peu plus haut de l'histoire
de ses deux fils juste avant de vous
laisser à cette conversation là on va
les remercier nos commandes
[Musique]
le podcast cette semaine et présenté par
epic souhaite
une compagnie du boss à la rade amqui
pour être plus précis aller en cui est
un show un coup
tout le monde
une compagnie qui est spécialisée dans
les vêtements les accessoires technique
pour le sport fait que c'est vraiment
des vêtements de qualité autant pour les
hommes que pour les femmes y ont même
des vêtements unisexes mais c'est pas
juste pour le sport de performance eu
aussi des gammes pour le streetwear
comme nous importe en ce moment dès
maintenant vraiment confortable vous
parlez de juin comporte un petit peu
plus tard par mois de ventes en mode
épique suez +2 et une gamme qui 100%
fait au québec piqué éco-responsable en
fait c'est important pour but
d'encourager nos entreprises locales à
des clients à faire afin de réduire leur
empreinte écologique enfin de s'assurer
que la pratique son éthique accusation
que shanghai il respecte l'environnement
et irrespect que les humains il respecte
le cycle de vie du cycle de la vie
il vient toujours sorti la nouvelle
collection à s-21 et tendre est
entièrement fabriqué ici comme on disait
encore une fois des matériaux éco
responsable coton biologique ou
polyester recyclé ce pas qu'ils soient
pour les sportifs ou pour les gens de
plein air ou pour les gens qui veulent
porter des vêtements confortables au
quotidien c'est pour vous qui vous voyez
pas en fait en ce moment dans l'équipe a
expliqué que ça commence à flasher ce
qu'ils voient sur youtube le c'est
vraiment un beau design et pépette par
une artiste québécoise effectif c'est
vraiment de la bombe lorlanges paiement
envoyées à moi du linge de course à pied
en fait pour eux pour que j'utilise lors
de la course à pied puis honnêtement
vêtements techniques de grande qualité
on a un code promo pour vous offre
exclusive qui est 20% de rabais dans le
code sans filtre 20 fait aller
encourager une compagnie québécoise
utiliser notre code 20% de rabais qui
tout le monde gangs fait que mercy et
pêchu et détruisent le postage
aujourd'hui est présenté par studio sf
le lieu dans lequel on se bat
présentement le studio cf vous pouvez le
louer pour réaliser vos projets des
créations vidéos de podcasts
d'enregistrement vocal de toutes sortes
livres audio des livres audio pour venir
ici et on va vous accompagner dans la
création de votre compte et en plus si
ce taux est en train de passer à l'oni
voulons ligne des ménages à zurich dans
un nouveau local comme tu pouvoir il
faut avoir plusieurs cette ope plusieurs
locaux on va en voir si un endroit pour
pour geler pour être cosy pour être bien
pour recevoir les invités fax ici que ça
se passe pour récréation de tout contenu
enchantement podcast même reconnaît le
fond ni ou suis fière si vous n'avez
même pas besoin de vous soucier d'aucun
point technique passion dans notre
équipe de techniciennes et techniciens
qui vont s'occuper de vous qui vont au
bout à bout
prendre dans ce projet là et s'assurer
que tout soit comme vous le voulez vous
n'avez qu'a vous concentrer sur la
création de votre contenu puis on
s'occupe de tout le reste calée au
studio sf point ca pour avoir plus
d'informations sur ce qui est bon test
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bref si vous avez commencé justement
genre 5 6 ans maintenant arrêtez de une
fois deux fois semaine puis à chaque à
chaque cours se découpent
georges fenech j'avais trop froid
surtout la piscine je vais t'en servir
la cour dans la passion puis il y avait
tout le temps un qui relaie non je tue
temps rien faire mais puis faisait
n'importe quoi
mais gerba place du coach jean à chaque
ça je le serai avec ces noms restants
continue puis le genre je me souvenais a
dit que je comprends que je gagne qui me
disait qui sort de l'eau puis j'en mets
ton petit bol à ta serviette à chaque
fois je me rappelle mon père
raja naqqash et j'ai juste comme je le
sais ce dont je parle à personne
paiement fameux cri après ça va j'ai
pris un bon temps passé dessus le gars
qui voit moins le crier après toi que de
son tour tombé à l'eau le
sarouel whincup la vol bon bien les 3 go
way 1 2 3 go les feuilles merci d'être
là elle est vous sur le temps de tokyo
ou encore le hip hop et
ça va faire deux semaines dans les dix
prochains
et demi et premier jour et rsa va bien
mais zoda fossé cela c'était aussi que
les conditions définies vous y voir m
mais n'ont été en back up les deux pour
les relais arrière j'ai eu la chance
qu'on a fini de manger quoi le 29 et on
est parti le dup en compte cinq et on a
eu la chance de vivre un peu le village
que vit depuis trois jours
c'était pas de tours à cause de la coved
et renvoie le jour dès que tu finis
travail anne gagné des parts mais si
c'est puis même il y avait d'autres
nageurs de d'autres pays et gérer les
amis de la france puis jeune fille à la
paix pour entrer en semi finale du 200 m
4 nages le lendemain matin était dans
l'avion et d'aller même pas eu le temps
de voir les cinq minutes la finale de sa
course à eux d'un point le monde elle
partira sinon ce n'est pas le même pas
la même ambiance que ce n'est pas même
en guinée en epic et les amis mais ces
poches ne mette à mal vus par des
migraines car oui
mais tout le monde n'y a tellement parlé
il m'attend c'est la pré liste
ci dessus c'est une des légendes c'est
vraiment si
je veux savoir ce à la hauteur de ce
qu'on dit c'est qui les lie regardons
ces sites la fosse aux yeux moi je me
suis fait avoir par la job classé comme
tout le monde dise l'hélianthe sexe plat
prayssas et cadence pas des liens du
sexe jusqu'à
les imaginer
quelqu'un qui voulait aller ou pas dans
la liste sa marge de paris
mais oui est en carton mais mettez là
bas aux élites un quartier c'était très
sale les maquettes en plastique le fait
que
tant qu'on porte
aux crs et laisser assez de cette classe
le sommet de la performance humaine
aller le père volage
animal pour l'heure aucun jeu là dans
toute l'histoire de sagesse a jamais été
confortable on est dans des camps
deschamps on y trouvera pas accommoder
onze mille athlètes dont
on peut mettre ce budget plus sur les
installations et non le confort
je me rappelle en 2006 libre à vélo
attaqué
en 2016
je me rappelle l'équipe de basket
américaine tout de go ce genre de spie
sud puis lebron james j'avais juste
louer un bateau des jambes ainsi
grognards de bateaux de croisière pour
tuer en basketball usaid toutes les
gammes
moyennes
car guingamp
alors qu'ils ont juste un petit peu là
parce qu'il ya d'enfants tués
tokyo 2020 en 2021 ça a été reporté les
olympiques une fois mais les essais ça a
été reportée genre 3 4 fois
mais cela pour ceux qui nous écoutent le
dans le fond le ce parce que ta
préparation tafer en vue d'une
compétition qui les essais olympiques
sur tout et vous êtes d' excellente
nageuse mais vous n'êtes pas
bonne au point ne pouvoir pas être
préparés aux essais de faire les
nationalement il se prépare quand même
pas beaucoup d'opportunités dans une
année de se préparer qui était en en
hausse de 0,1 point puis mais surtout
pour un coach nous on parle notre coach
et l'italie étaient calmes on était
désespérés ils étaient on commence la
tpe il faut remonter au recommence à des
peurs il faut remonter ces puis c'était
assez dur pour lui aussi pour nous était
anxieux james t parce qu'elle sait
surtout à tout le temps quand tu es 11
10 aces c'est importer pendant un an qui
sait le cette date si on arrive trois
semaines avant puis au nom c'est dans un
mois et demi un fait que le décès de
thor s'était petit dieu qui dans un mois
et demi je capable d'attendre puis ça
fait deux ou trois fois think tank il
tant que ça l'est plus pour ouvrir le
nous on avait quand même tout à la crème
que sa régie sur
le planai
l'imam les essais puis le y en a qui ont
qui ont des compétitions dont le pôle
droit au québec on était tellement
strictes pour leur faire des
compétitions il en est qui en ont eues
c'est que on voit partout dans le monde
partout dans le monde y en avait nom
avait posté c'était frustrant c'était
angoissant c'était aussi avec les
journaux tout qu'est-ce qu'ils se
battraient plaisir de vendre des jeux va
pas avoir de jeu le mécontentement des
gens à tokyo et où puisez moustey faut
pas se laisser emporter par qu'est ce
qui dit qu'il faut se concentrer avec
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire c'est ce qui
te rend difficile le restant de moments
présence d'un trou s'est projeté peu
importe ce qui arrive on se prépare
comme ça veut dire
de méditer quand mais comment tu fais
pour pau comme stressé touche puis le
gid il faut que le focus une journée à
la fois parce que même avec la coved à
chaque jour ça changeait
piste et si on avait été vu qu'on avait
quand même un très beau groupe dans le
sens où c'est quand on prend l'exemple
en élégant même choyés cette année dit
jeudi ron à cause des conditions on
était comme cohabitent dans le groupe on
avait chacun autres corridors tournée
mais c'était génial comme comme comme
ambiance d'entraînement
tipiak a mis un genre de plusieurs
mamans os qui avait pas de natation oui
mais nous on a eu le droit à leur
commencé en juillet fac de mars à
juillet on n'avait rien qu'appréciez
salaires fermés pendant six semaines à
l'automne puis à partir de la pression
mais quand même il doit mais je m'en
aller c'est dans un groupe mais tu y en
avait des plus jeune fille sasha qui
avait un report un report des déficits
et je me rappelle les plus jeunes vis
des combats ce programme et on va là
2024 oui et non
car
c'est nous on veut aller le genre il y
en aura pas de 2024 pour moi peut-être
elle met ses jardins c'est fou sur les
inspectrices est tellement
éloignés dans le top 4 à l'amont du
sport c'est l'éternité vous pourrez
charger en quatre ans mais ça va être
tellement vite en même temps comme il ya
tellement de choses qui se passent ces
clowns messieurs mais c'est moi je me
disais tu en 2005 j'avais des chances
pis ça peut bien été j'ai troqué aux
essais bref pile de me dire que depuis
2016 a maintenant cinq ans mais il ya
tellement eu de trucs tu es jeux parti
vivre en turquie pendant un an et demi
il entend affecter s'il ya tellement de
trucs en même temps c'était hier j'ai
besoin que je reviens
c'est une fou autant qui est sûre garde
substrat tellement passé rapidement
autant que se prend d'année en année
comme tabarnouche s'en est passé des
trucs même après ça c'est même moi
mettons en rétrospective la toute toute
ma carrière attention quand même duré
toute ma carrière natation dans ma tête
semble être
ultra courtes on dirait que les années
maintenant sont vraiment plus longue que
des 5 1 d'avant
le train pour seulement vite on était
là-bas pire des cas pas bah c'est fini
c'est fini les eaux avec ce week-end à
magna non non au nom de pesanteurs c'est
comme
si tous ces mini
j'aimais pas qu'à réaliser ouais
mais
les vingt et un de natation 20 ans
apparaît comme un flash j'aime et j'ai
fait les essais en 2008 tobin premier
essai jusqu'en 2016 puis tout ça était
genre un bref instant si oui je n'aurai
pas de dix ans de ma vie entre 6 et 16
ans mais tant pis si aujourd'hui ça me
paraît comme un autre vigeant oui ça me
paraît comme gentil qui ne gâche pas
quand je vais faire mon marché quand je
défends moment georges et georges déjà
dans mon ancienne vie maintenant voilà
servis
dans son ancienne vie déjà ce n'était
que ce que tu fais il
avait rien d'autre
tout le sait tous les jours bernard
l'esprit maintenant jeu tellement dans
un autre milieu d'un peuple des fois
j'ai exactement bits et enfants n'ont
aucune dignité moi dans mon ancienne vie
qu'est ce que t'en as ton nom c'est une
vie je faisais des compétitions natation
les olympiques dans le fond le ça était
quoi votre
les semaines qui ont l'idée jusqu'à
tokyo dans le fond parce que tu es fou
de calmer les essais ont vraiment été
rapprochées d'ici un mois avant pâques
on est revenu une semaine quoi puis on y
reparlera vancouver à vancouver a besoin
de 3 heures d'abord on devait aussi
faire une campagne 41 ans de bettembourg
de semaine
il était temps d'aller à tokyo fait
qu'on a vécu c'est ce qu'on a fait en
équipe si on avait eu droit un peu de
sorties mais on n'avait pas le droit d
on est des poules où se met en mode qui
coince et cfa qui ont été le plus
apprécié en italie au jeu et quoi quatre
jours avant dix à douze accords est
vraiment prendre
plutôt qu'une certaine date je pense que
quatre jours avant mais le décalage de
vancouver c'est comme ça
c'était aux arts ici faite devant croire
ces gens
8h55 quatre jours mais
c'est la compétition la plus importante
de l'année de la vie de toutes ces
athlètes le pineau style sheet l'autre
d'athlètes le lyonnais tarnac le théier
pas dire ce qu'ils gagnent des médailles
on y reviendra parce qu'il ya un article
paru hier je pense que tu perds deux
seuls messi comme c'est
l'accomplissement ultime de toutes ces
années là tu leur donnes quatre jours
200 m dans huit heures décalage puis
dorment sur du carton
pour moi c'est un ep qui ont choqué
c'est qu'en mer on
rajoute elle était imaginable monde
toujours l'habitude de faire primer le
matin final le saura plus tard pour la
première fois à 12 mois depuis 16 ans
que je mangerai pour la première fois
l'ont fait les primes dans le
simplifiant le matin ouais c'est l'un
des gros succès pour ma plus grosse
compagnie ce que peut faire dans la
ville tant que la raison pas créé vers
ce c'est parce que ici pour
les droits télévisés
de l'argent pour le plan
comptable c'est pas l'athlète en
profondeur pour l'athlétisme par exemple
au nom l'athlétisme il ya les courses de
genre
de grâce ouais le sample 200 hommes sont
comme les les épreuves les plus
regardées les stèles matin pour vour
nous y intéresser à dire que l'hôtel
soit puis finissait la journée avec sûr
mais peut-être que hec peut voir son
salaire était bien en natation ben ouais
non mais c'est en même temps que moi je
pense à mon team m'a pris le relais
mais comme des finales
100%
mais non mais que j'avais à dire et il y
en a beaucoup qui je me suis déjà fait
ces commentaires étaient tellement passé
tellement glamour et dans les
territoires de capital
et c'est génial
mais dans un monde idéal vous arriveriez
genre un mois avant le béton non j'ai la
banane on était censé aller faire un
camp d'entraînement au japon et c'était
tellement strictes au japon n'aurait pas
eu droit de sortir on aurait dit on a
été enfermé dans une chambre d'hôtel
mais 84 je pense qu'on sera viré
nécessaires en plus et j'avais parlé un
coach de plongeon puis il ya fait toutes
les sélections pour les jeux entre que
bref il y avait une compétition à tokyo
qui l'ont un peu vécu cette expérience
ces expériences là bas mais il ya un
pote sortir dehors puis une fois qu'ils
ont pu puis emmenés dans un
stationnement wakil fait de marcher dans
les stationnements intérieurs comme des
prisonniers ressorti pis c'est tout
l'été la seule aire frêche qui ont eu de
tout leur voyage c'était vraiment très
strictes fait que tu veux pas dépasser
un genre de deux jours deux semaines
d'abord créé dans les circonstances
sinon c'est au tarif le sait si je mets
à ty à petit dans les autres
compétitions on est tout le temps un
camp dans la même mesure
mal mais je pense que c'est mieux pour
la santé mentale de rester au pays puis
surtout côté avant que vous nous quand
on est parti les masques étaient même
plus obligatoire mais on a quand même
pas le droit de sortir vraiment fait
qu'on était quand même en bill métier on
voyait comment ça devenait de plus en
plus les pour un pays où vous au pays
alors que tu japon s'est reconverti
street west st strict strict serait que
la voûte est vraiment aux échecs et
maintenant les îles ont fait plus peur
maladive par le koala du japon wa kébé
ça fait vraiment plus peur qu'on pensait
il nous avait dit je vous aurais pas le
droit de parler à vos amis des autres
pays voudraient pas le droit de parler
aux autres tout ce qu'ils
les personnes qui étaient à côté de nous
ils n'auront pas le dessus cgt on allait
les masques en permanence en tirions
était même sanctionné la voix dans la
chambre mais coûte ça fait genre deux
ans qu'on est ensemble à toulouse
et lille que vous l'auriez dès
qu'on sortait de la chambre ces masques
en permanence et on avait peur à sortir
des villages sont et heymans et demi si
même dans la cafétéria y avait des
plexiglas parfumé titre et le
déconnecter en face de l'autre en
sortant des poules ouais mais à côté on
se mettait tout un côté qui on parle
mais le match pendant la cérémonie des
médailles c'est triste si je trouve ça
triste j'ai de la misère à regarder sur
sans vouloir me met à pleurer le tour du
monde sont même acclamé d'haïti comme la
faucille accomplissement d'une ville
pleut tellement il faut juste les yeux
qui ont qui sont comme remplit de fierté
et de joie les photos ça va être juste
un essai tous les américains et leurs
masques
batman ce qui était dégueulasse là
a été long je veux qu'ils renault avec
un an je sais pas s'il a décidé de faire
ça
[Musique]
vrai pari engagé au moins ils enlevaient
pour le genre une photo la
relève le pourquoi il avait rejeté dans
tes on respecte ça mais après ça on
prend les autobus on est soixante ans
une auto bus on est toujours les pays
toutes les tons de oui on est mince mais
bon selon la piscine le
jeudi on a un peu de muscle je sortais
de la piscine et j'étais heureux du
succès vraiment extrême que nos
qualifications et les qualifications à
nu le
chrono pour manger ils sont allés manger
quelques fois ci par m on avait une
place à castries pour mon geste un petit
corps et c'est pas plus que 5 minutes
puis mises en situations la prime de mes
courses je mange la réglisse j'ai fini
ma combi mon coach me donne la réglisse
je le mange la madame est qu il faut que
tu ailles de l'autre côté de la porte il
ya personne pour la province et il pleut
je maquille pas de problème je m'assois
sur le banc qui
de l'autre côté de la porte à rien me
voir et que non si paul c'est juste à
côté d'accord
j'ai dû mettre dans le caritatif est
acquis c'est bon et non aux essais et
aux qualifications c'était quelque chose
mais est on a craché médecine a su le
ballet qu'il fallait qu'on le remette à
ce que ces personnes tu vois je relis
célébration canadien gagne tout le monde
sont 120 milles des personnes mais les
ont jetées en live le candidat la bulle
il ya eu pas mal de passes droite pour
les cananéens s'intégrant du cil pas
juste et pour nous en tant que tel mais
je pense pour tous les athlètes parce
que tu y avait dit que le droit par
rapport à aucun des 41 mois parce qu'il
faisait veut que la rigueur
mais les athlètes olympiques on n'était
pas exempté donc si on voulait pas
refaire compétition parce qu'on a un peu
pas de faire des compétitions qui ont de
la seule façon pour nous de faire des
compétitions c'était de sortir du pays
mais s'en sortait du pays fallait faire
deux semaines à 40 m next est impossible
pour nous parce qu'on peut pour la même
source il à propos d'europe de l'est
si on a trouvé ça vraiment du style de
thé on comprenait pour le game ssm et
faites le pour vous acquitter d'un pic
surtout si cette année fixée moi
personnellement je
vais apprécier si on fait pour les
athlètes fait les prout pestel personne
telle personne si tout le monde mais
c'est sûr mais
c'était débile plus mais en même temps
tu dis mais il va toujours avoir
l'argent qui va dileo tout seul c'est le
convoi qui est des sports professionnels
du sport amateur
c'est ça c'est cela
commençait petit
les canadiens à montréal c'est là la
foule se seraient déjà que les gens
ressentent réprimer c'est comme ça va
vite ça
les gens ce rallye d'allemagne il ya
personne qui a des crises d'un moi aussi
si les athlètes avaient pas leur masse
sur le péno mais ces personnes car
j'ai mis une photo à manille on sortait
durée l'élève chaussée mais huit mois on
est dans les brousses j'ai reçu des
messages vos maçon ou
[Musique]
plus
les jo puis cette avance clotis est
tellement chez qui est que la barre des
2 kg et est si avancée rendu un excès de
zèle
ou non mais pour qui peter est vrai mais
tant que les images le d c'est l'effet
de ce pasteur au 100 brasse comme tous
les frissons mairie allégeant les cartes
ce calibre ne risque rien en face c'est
vraiment un bon moment
d'écrire à toi
masculine arias bleu qu'on l'attendait
qu'ils ont fini de nous ranger
côté
people
au niveau personnel cammas a été au
niveau des performances vous avez paix
est on si vous aviez arrêté seul et
concrètement ça s'est passé en action de
5 en
1 minute 56
nécessaire dans le fond mais c'est moi
et je pense c'est une des seules qui
avait pas encore course et puis
j'attendais que je voyais tout le monde
bien faire porter tout est classé pour
le 4 x 200 m et le relais exactement
c'est que moi ça allait bien à
l'entraînement j'étais prête j'avais
horde de femmes apportent un petit peu
sur l'équipe parce que si je voyais tout
le monde
canadien
à mon tour je peux bien faire aussi bleu
j'avais autre plaie
je t'ai plus excité je t'ai pas trop
stressé puis je me rappel après le 4 x 2
il y avait signé qui sortie de la
piscine plein ciel
plein jour à la piscine
non
sadry moins de minutes les rings c'est
une bonne chose qui s'adresse
mais
moins de six breaks et je n'ai pas
encore réalisé mais moi personnellement
comme de performance est gérante est
satisfaite a été mon meilleur temps à
vie qui j'ai jamais ne sait pas nager
aussi vite depuis les cinq dernières
années dont j'ai fini ma saison puis oui
ça s'est passé rapidement mais je peux
dire que j'ai hâte à la prochaine vidéo
du prochain jeu j'attends que ça te
donner sa bombe flanc droit ça me donne
un petit avant goût parce que ce n'est
pas l'expérience qu'on m'a vendu n'était
pas dense le zizou mais tout le monde
dit c'est pas là pour la période
d avant goût avec quito d'équipage fait
manuelles jeux panaméricains de jeu
exactement pu le tester les next ft sur
le sujet un petit avant goût si sa
petite idée sur
mes lèvres porte attendre trois ans mais
ces trois ans régis out le plus qu'à
maquiller prochaine fois tu es japon ce
fait relève je veux faire d'autres
épreuves avec pour ce je suis content
d'avoir fait religieux même si t'es pas
nécessairement ce que je m'attendais
juste pour me donner la passion pour les
trois prochaines années de m'entraîner
de revenir tu disais c'est que tu le
peux réaliser sur le coup puis je pense
qu'avant qu'on se mette à tourner tu dis
que tu l'avais toujours pauvre vraiment
réaliser ouais tu penses qu'à manille
trouver le bon matin paul avoir réalisé
des clips que c'est pour ça veut dire le
réaliser et tu sais pas ce que c'est un
rêve que vous avez ainsi seuls à faire
ce qu'il veut pas heurter un muret de
petites fées et pis c'est jeudi c'est
puis je pense que c'est le rêve la
plupart des athlètes ans qui commence
les jeunes qu'ils entassent dans un
sport surtout dans ce sport le dans le
sport amateur exactement tel article
puis oui j'étais talentueuse quand
j'étais jeune puis je passe ce sont les
journées tous les gens attendent dans un
article à 10 ans c'était l'été de
l'article c'était je vais à laujuzan
l'épée une plaie t on leeson ce pays de
10 ans à 3 horrifiant
il souhaite bonne chance mais l'effet de
12 ans plus tard je peux dire que ça
s'est fait puis oui ça aurait pu nous
sommes été facile il ya eu des hauts et
des bonnes mais que ça a été fait on
dirait que c'est que l'espèce
était ce mais qu'est ce que tu sais pas
ce que c'est je souhaitais ce
sont ceux qui nous écoutent la six
[Rires]
parce que je voyais ces quelques jours
de ce
qu'est ce que
c'est une bonne question parce que je
t'aiderai que c'est un mix des deux
voies dans le sens que je pense pas que
c'est l'expérience que je m'attendais de
vivre je pense que je vais pouvoir la
vivre en 2024 mais pour l'instant c'est
un stacy
bonds mais c'est la farce
aimant peace river qui toutes façons un
sérieux c'est d'autant plus un nom mais
si c'est si je prends pas ça pour acquis
rien des bleus mais d'ici là encore de
ce que je m'attendais fait que moi
j'entends encore les trois corps bon je
pense que rendu à paris je peux te dire
c'était cool
parce que c'est quand même particulier
des tirs justement c'est tellement le
rêve de tout sportif d'aller leur
travail vers substitut tu rêves de te
une fois qu'il fait qu'est ce qui se
passe ici comme bombay on leur fait ou
ccc comme ma faute a toujours voulu que
blizzard défilé en défilé loin car tout
le vécu pieter feith le pod d'après
reprise
qu'est ce qui se passe dans nathalie
bâton après des premiers c'est quoi
après me premier j'avais du temps à moi
j'étais sûr avec moi c'était déjà en
2012 c'est une surprise que je sois le
fac moi j'étais convaincu que j'allais à
l'heure des messages pressants des
messages je pensais que c'était fini
j'avais j'ai arrêté j'ai recommencé le
jeu suit le et laisser complètement une
autre mine bing parce que dans ce petit
ce qui s'est passé nom et devient année
on dirait que c'est ce que c'est ce que
je vis plus que l'expérience des jeux en
tant que telle et j'apprécie le moment
de toutes les années que j'ai eu depuis
l'été chaque athlète eux sont parfois
non exhaustif et
c'est là qu'elle fois tu avais trois
forte à laquelle fois que mettons la
pression était la plus forte ou que
c'était le plus c'est dessus à rio où
c'est sous la pression la plus forte je
crois honnêtement c'était bien en 2012
ouais ok parce que j'arrivais j'étais
jeune
j'étais quand tu sais que mon ascension
chez que la jeune carrie identiques aux
tirets
mettait beaucoup de pression à moi même
encore je pense que je sais pas si j'ai
pas assez mature non plus pour vivre ce
type d'expérience le je pense avec du
recul quand je réfléchis à tout ce je
pense qu'il manquait pas vraiment
d'expérience de maturité je me mettais
énormément de pression moi même j'avais
l'impression que dans ma tête mais ma
mère était dans les estrades du fallait
que je nageais deux parce que ma mère
était l'hôte et puis je me mettais
toujours dépression puis les jaunards
laisser la première fois moi j'avais des
journalistes derrière moi en 2012 si je
commençais pas que comme les médias et l
heure puis j'ai comme pau suggéré cette
pression-là bref mais ça me préparer
pour 2011 par contre l'idée mais ça
c'est un autre ambiance parce qu'ils
aient jeté dans une épreuve que j'avais
jamais fait de mon mieux fait que
c'était complètement différent j'avais
pas l'attendre pente et parce que tu as
fait le souhait de s'enflammer aux 2,5
roll j'avais raté la qualification dans
ma meilleure épreuve vous parlions pas
ce que c'est les essais olympiques c'est
une fois sur youtube suivent aussi il va
pas je les ai ratées je tâche même si
j'ai eu la chance de me classer dans un
épreuve un autre mais titre 6e j à
l'aide pour un relais plein dans ma tête
on m'a demandé c'est comme un objectif
mon amateurs de ski quand mais je sais
pas ça des fans trois autres filles je
n'ai pas d'objectif accès difficile pour
son jeu au pied du team matech logement
depuis on n'avait pas de châtillon
savais pas qu'on avait des chances de
médaille avant le savent en 2016 avant
de croiser le canada
bonjour les gars c'est un sport c'est
pour ça que c'est même peu dans nos
têtes jectif c'était même plus facturer
j'avais pas de pression j'avais pu c'est
ce qui cette année mais en fait je
voulais pas même impression parce
qu'avec ce que j'ai vécu je pense que je
sais juste fier de ce que j'ai fait je
pense que c'est ce qui je voulais aller
l'a déjà je me suis surprise en fait
d'être revenu à ce niveau là et cette
erreur je pense tu me son bâton ce que
tu avais été là
sans forcer en est avec toi même le
béton conçues par lula
en fait est ce que tu penses que l'année
de plus tôt idée
est ce que tu penses que tu aurais fait
les jeux sans l'année de plus
je me croyais prête en 2020 je réalise
que je l'étais pas puis je me croyais
prête en mars 2021 puis je réalise que
je n'étais pas puis je pense que tout
les mots que j'ai eu de plus ont été
extrêmement bénéfique pour moi parce que
tu es jeune et en scène cacherai pas je
suis parti de loin parce que j'avais
arrêté en 2008 revenir déjà regardé mi
temps mais quand j'ai recommencé les
deux cartes 200 livres qui ont commencé
un peu sa faim ça ça ça prend beaucoup
et quand même de travail pour serre
méthane 50/50 sous le voile de kite des
conneries
sport qui se partagent rapidement
intéressant je me suis juste et mettons
dans le temps si on
mène of tu reviendras loupé ça comme le
pire des marges en
gros c'est ça et là on arrêtait dijon
y vuelta tous en commun
[Rires]
la journée le
matin atelier fabrique ton reconnu ce et
bien fait sur ce qu'ils connaissaient
claude dans ce que je sais moi je sais
pas si c'est vrai c'est fac et je sais
pas
ce que c'est parce qu'elle a lot c'est
paul gray man
mais moi je sais le carénage et mentale
est énorme c'est parce qu'en fait j'ai
pu y croire soi-même que tes gars de
revenir le séduire c'est une fille ça
m'a pris du temps à y croire revenir aux
articles c'est ça ton gardien comment
dire commencer puis moi je me protégeais
encore émotionnellement dix ans bah
c'est pas grave j'ai déjà été jugée
naïve exposera au petit que si c'est la
protection et moi si je dois vous époque
c
est parce que si je suis encore là c'est
clairement passé ça m'importe peu parce
que c'est pas grave waouh mais aux yeux
des autres moi je me disais ben je vais
leur dire que c'est pas grave parce que
tu sais comme une protection situé le
spo basse programme d autres pensent que
ce programme fait ici les autres me
croit quand je leur dise pas grave et
qu'ils me répondent que ce pas grave
peut-être commencer à croire moi même
et s'est séparé c'est pareil c'est la
protection puis tiens ça m'a pris du
temps à y croire car année je croyais un
petit peu plus un petit peu plus s'y
multiplient plus pandémie
mais bon honnêtement à la pandémie je
sais pas je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
mentalement mais même s'il ya eu tout ce
qui s'est passé
ça me donne est simple mais ça va
affecter dans le sens où ça m'affecter
dans la peur d'eux pour réussir ce
mets tes même quand on est revenu en
juillet je sais que ça allait bien quand
même c'est tellement heureuse alf apps
si cette année moi j'ai mis cette année
en italie il n'y a pas eu de xlr
l'époque beaucoup d'autres choses à
faire que de s'entraîner fort exact mais
ça c'est vrai par exemple le titre
j'aime aussi dans le fond c'est ce que
c'est une année où j'ai calé ce migrant
dit personnellement puis comme étant
dans mon sport ultra amateurs que je
fais maintenant que la course à pied
l'été ça m'a permis de vraiment
m'entraîner plus sérieusement parce que
je me dis ah chemist chauffard quest v
passe au dessus c'est ça le fait ça a
été une année où est ce qui était appelé
personnellement qu'on a appris à
apprécier ce qu'on avait fait je pense
que je prenais un petit peu la natation
pour acquis le fait de ne pas pouvoir
faire ce que je fais depuis quand même
15 16 ans au quotidien ça me remise en
perspective du fait que h&m sentation
pis vraiment chanceuse de faire
d'être cité niveau le fait que je pense
que je voyais déjà bacsinszky est plus
joyeuse du fait que j'apprécie d'être
ici dans mon entraîneur de montrer leur
exigeant motivés et puis c'est tellement
plus facile à cause du sud puis on se
l'est dit souvent allez mettez une
chance conserver mettons ouais parce que
t on ça fait deux ans qu'on avait pas
compétitionner contre personne personne
pas que la seule comparaison que moi
j'avais c'était elle la seule
comparaison que la veste et moir c qui
on savait aucune menace que les autres
pays au pays faisait parce qu'elle est
peu plus de compétition pittis a
personne ne dit que terra pax et nous on
savait si on était bon si on était sur
la bonne voie en se comparant l'une
l'autre c'est un effort et puis on sait
mlle mais c est dur des fois parce qu'en
occultant comparaison tout le temps en
compétition pas qui mais en même temps
une chance concept en tabarnak après la
percée trois témoins et vite if rue de
cette liste ça va de journée en journée
il était chaque entraînement est
différent mais tu es maintenant une
journée où est ce que catherine danger
bien plus on mange mange est pas bien
plus des communautés j'aurais aimé ce
pourra suivre puis vice versa fft s'est
quand même dit sa vérité sur le mode
free contre lui on ne
comprend absolument mois à peu près le
jeu sort que 50% des chicanes que j'ai
eu avec à l'export il est lié à ce
c'était lié au petit on sent très bien à
l'extérieur de la piscine le méchant du
poignet le bec souvent le pas sur stylia
ce à cause de tout ce qu'on répète dans
la pratique on partait en à côté de
l'autre puis des fois c'est lui qui
gagne à d'autres six mois ferme et c'est
comme de gasmi compétitif c'est en
voyant tabarnak
classique boss le dernier à l'ordre
public mais c'est ça la laïcité c'est
dans notre fibre la compétition des
piscines le
choix c'est normal mais c'est moi je
pense pas que j'arrivais le sang elle
seule cette année puis les deux
dernières années puis c'est un peu notre
coach aussi puisque lier le wifi qui
n'ont jamais mes preuves dit factice et
comme quand les forfaits des simulations
de compétition mais ryanair qui va bien
et l'autre qui va mal avec les du bravo
à eux ni va consoler leur place et c'est
tout le temps si ça s'est inversé c'est
jamais parfaite aux pays pauvres est si
ça ne faisait pas aussi les alizés salle
un pays classé comme qu'est ce que ça
fait s'il y en a une qui signifie paulo
ouais pas se déplacer sur les deux qu'on
fasse l'équipe tu es le meilleur
scénario pole mais avait plusieurs
scénarios qui on s'entend qui est
le scénario qui est moi je pensais même
quand j'ai fini mais je sais mais je me
mettais sur un pic steak cataye allez y
pour moi parce qu'ils m'ont dit
d'attendre et la choriste sera terminée
l'infect toute la semaine j'étais dans
l'incertitude l'idée autant j'étais
tellement contente pour 4 puis 6 après
apprend journée le mois et 4 cm à mot le
sert dans le forez à franges en épis à
qui je vais retourner en arrière
là - c 'est la veille je m'appelle
jacques j'attends un et coéquipier
piatti tchèque de 24 avec classe et au
centre laval son fleuve lay j'ai posée
pourquoi la série parce qu'à s'entraîner
pas pour ça c'était pas son look et
audiovisuelle d'eau chaude et j'allais
vu s'entraîner ou quatre ans mais
je le savais assisté au cap à voter
demain puis dix autres avaient vu son
speed avait des soeurs de l'egypte est j
je te le dis figé cheikh demain pilet t
elle avait sa finale de son flair
j'avais un final de son dos un peu plus
tard qui de ce fait à ce que l'eau soit
100 m papillon puis j'étais tellement
contente dans les temps je t'ai
dit oui je te contentes mais là je te
reverrai aussi le faire au 112 7 à mon
tour maintenant de le faire puis le
laisser en domota aussi sur vasilis et
c'est la précision de monsanto
malheureusement je me suis pas classés x
a été assez difficile mais j'ai aussi
besoin était les deux on a les émotions
comme contre les églises mais quand même
cela c'est bon ils voudraient à notre
homme croisé moi l'élément la jeunesse
finir à quoi l'on sait en direct et jeux
tetris pour étancher tellement contente
pour elle plonge obligé à regarder pour
ne pas pleurer alors c'est là répandant
comme cinq minutes là c'est des émotions
qu'on partagera personnes dotées parce
qu'on le vécu ensemble subtil c'est ça
moi j'avais tellement peur que ce soit
pas le scénario est parfait qu'on avait
été dit le fait qu'on se casse les 2 200
m libre mais ou quatre fois 2e des
scénarios société comme là on n'était
pas l'une contre l'autre vous avez mangé
ensemble et m'étais imaginé ok on est à
la finale des essais olympiques on est
deux québécoises puis à 6 fait du même
club en ontario si on est les deux là
pour l'aider comme le lait mais huit
c'est notre tour on le fil ouais c il
allait à ccc s'étoffe on est on est tous
les deux dans leurs débuts à paris comme
le sénat chance et faut pas combattre
entre les deux types a rapporté une
vidéo navarrete manger on est plus sur
le radar depuis quelques années le stade
québécoises et de québécois étaient les
deux seuls les hommes bolt au stage
national aura finalement posé sans répit
pour les sociétaires de fainéants
montréal mais il n'avait pas vu venir on
était comme des tâches qui leur
est candidat je suis vient de s'imposer
ici c'est certain a raison parce qu'en
mai
certains timides attraper la fois on
était les deux on était assis l'un à
côté de l'autre c'était tout les fixes
qui sont un groupe majeur d'une wii et
on s'est regardé dans le cas des objets
y sont encore aussitôt on était le pire
c'était son ambiance l'hôtel puisque
c'est les filles sont toutes comme joris
féliciter ils discutent ensemble est non
et les deux assis sur une chaise une
toile y aller vite fait à six à dix
mètres de distance et puis là il ya une
fille qui va se lever let's go abbas qui
tombent à plat et let's go sommes ici
parce que dans un autre centre
mais ça bascule t il nous aime pas non
plus mais société imagine tous la même
chose si on est un groupe 100 trains
transitent ici comme on veut le même
rail nous citons voulais pas que ce soit
les autres on voulait que ce soit nous
tue plus mais si c'était une ambiance et
de jeu déjà que les red wings les plus
dans les plus d'intentions monde le voit
de tout le temps comme la personne
tellement intense exécuteur
des rangées de quelqu'un qui veut jouer
à tout le monde peu stressé tout bois de
toutes les faits décrits primal
de 50
sur les olympiques au regard des ligues
au
complet
la pilule qui comme moi
c'est pour qu'elles montrent qu'ils
écoutent qui comprennent rien l'enfant
si c'est l'espèce des pièces que vous
attendez à votre maman
fait avec seulement maintenant si je
fais juste expliqué le on embarque on
arrive à la piscine près de deux heures
avant notre course on embarque pour le
réchauffement dans l'eau une heure avant
pour 30 minutes si on fait peut prêcher
pour 1000 mah et 2005 ça dépend des
personnes 1500 m puis après ça on me
mettait le maillot il faut qu'on soit
dans la chambre d'appel ou qui vont
checker si notre maillot légale si notre
casque ailé gas nos lunettes sont les
galets quitter red dot accréditation 20
minutes avant d'autres courses voici
pour que toutes les 20 minutes le on est
assis sur une chaise
active outre très chaud fait vingt dix
minutes je change ça veut dire est que
la prostate atteinte exploitants dont
vingt quinze minutes avant la course
ouais avec thé avec tes ton opposition
dans le fond c'est évident
la tension est présent
jeudi
la côte est du genre
tu vois tu je suppose je pense que poser
un épais que le mail est faite une fois
nationaux puis je voulais me chier
dessus m'a
littéralement véhicule j'entends que les
meilleurs d'europe le tout et comme tu
te sens tu que moi c'est quand une messe
en terre je chante et je n'ai pas ma
place le cicuit
calice le dit rien aux olympiques dès le
mois d'octobre c'est comme les smartdate
cyclisme
puis à tulle à faire de
l'intimidation lancé pascal
thomas stache est le plus fort laisse
pourra peut montrer
le clos ouais chad le clos il est gentil
zoellick les boxes de même puis le faire
déjà à marjah avec son personnel en
propre
mais y en a qui le désirent y en a qui
disent que c'est une game enthalpie au
portage et lili king la brasserie ces
derniers et plm dis clairement je me
sens intimidée le monde pierre
darchicourt garde le monde rit fixe puis
je les ai signé bien là
puis une foire est une foule plonger
dans l'eau le tien après tout la
préparation vous avez fait
c'est quoi le pourcentage de l'épreuve
mais tombe la performance que te faut
faire qui physiquement
[Musique]
je trouve que tu es rendu aux jeux
olympiques tout le monde du ballon ouais
c'est le monde et tout se mettra
performant tout le monde est différent
qui moi je trouve que la différence
c'est le mental
mais on le voit les les athlètes et
genre des fois je comprends pas comment
il fonctionne fort mentalement ça mais
si c'est une
paix ni le peu la même ville de fo
retenter une
scène cac game heroes 2 100 crawl c'est
que tu as la faa le projet halo pas
gagné le com
enfin c'est une malchance de quelqu'un
est allé la chercher dans le dernier
carré non non à la une force mentale
puis des fois j'ai quitté des entrevues
de ska dit dans sa taille pendant une
course jusqu'à je pense pour une course
jusqu'aux halles explique à quoi
capacité à côté panse belle et comme les
gens criaient dans mad dans ma taille je
voulais lui que
je sais pas injuste allen force à la
laisse est plus beau que moi je vais pas
parler pour les autres mais si sûr
mais non mais non mais ça et ça se voit
c'est quelque chose des athlètes comme
seuls les athlètes comme ça qui
résonnent aux moments les plus
importants c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
l'entraînement le cpo la personne appui
exceptionnel à l'est quelque chose à
vous dire qu'elle allait mettre la
switch le commerce à metz à switcher nos
jules est si comme c'est mon moment les
piles apprend cette opportunité de
cdd gros best game sur des compétitions
super importante l'été mais alain petit
délinquant un côté mais positivement
mais un petit côté coquin plus loin je
pense à d'haïti ça doit d'abord
confiance
qu'à quatre points derrière le bloc a
doit toujours penser que je sais pas si
naturelles ou à le travailler ou chez
ses côtés pierre notte des mamans dans
notre visite et on a des moments où on
est plus fort que d'autres clubs où j'ai
eu des années où j'étais vraiment forte
mentalement que d'autres livres et moins
factice est elle aussi ça va y arriver
et ça y est arrivé chez terreur mais
n'empêche que ce cette année ça se
voyait c'est en fait je suis en garde et
ça se voit c'est pas que des gens comme
ça que ça se voit là quelque chose
autour d'elle le tournant social chose
adam pythie l'oeil et il y en a marre
des grades et bloque le pilier du jeu
qui veut ça apparaît dans son attitude
c'est flou il quelque chose de cause
d'une statue tatum et d'expliquer qu'un
entraînement des fois d'utiliser du jour
ça vaut mieux toit puis le des autres ne
doit plus et ça change métier vous
faites la même prière l'entraînement
vous avez parlement
nutrition sommeil pas mal semblables des
fois c'est doit expliquer tpiy qu'est ce
qui fait qu'une journée dure une bonne
preuve que ce qui fait que d'une faute
plan des fautes et de tout fait
correctement mois sa société charles
c'est ce qu'ils ont comme d'autres
réussissent là en même temps le sérum
c'est dur de réussir tout en même temps
égal le pti s'il ya des journées où ça
va être mentalement on va se reposer
puis revenant j'ai vite imité par
divulguer tout le temps mais tu es quand
tu es à ton pic l'été tout par film -
c'est ce que des fous tu plonges piteux
tout est parfait puis c'est comme c'est
comme une contre-performance seul
expliquer pourquoi non des fois mais tf1
et visiter des fois ça fait juste à être
plus réactif un coup de brut plus
souvent des missions comme ces cons là
c'est quand c'était voilà moi je me
rappelle le pitch sûr que ça vous est
déjà arrivé aussi puis d'homme aussi en
fait je pensais que c'était déjà en fait
je
mets 10 sur 1 200 mettant le mois de
s'acheter le truc c'est la pire la pire
distance le l'instance la plus tough l'
âge argué des com-zones pitt mettons
partir deux dixièmes plus vite afin que
ce que le temps que tu devrais partir
mettons le juste parts et un tout petit
peu plus crispé un tout petit peuple
tête tu vas payer comme ça l'eau de mer
dans le dernier 50
cl fous pareils un camarade plus c'était
trop tard hp à ces foules mais des fois
même mois un temps je suis dans une
course dans un 200 mètres le puits
mimoun vont changer genre tu es dans la
course mais tu as le temps de penser là
en deux minutes le meilleur
passeur du web je suis penser que les
gens ils posent des questions mais comme
je suppose que c'est pour être sur le
coup maintenant ont su le coulis saâd
ben et they went parti trop vite j'ai eu
mal aux jambes afin de me rappeler la
médaille mais il a beaucoup de gens les
georges
le lendemain je pouvais pas genre direct
pendant mon 200 il ya j'ai pensé à ça
c'est quand même jour mais à un problème
mais moi ça m'arrive des fois jeune âge
puisque non ça ne va pas ça marche
encore ouais films et des fois je veux
être au contraire que le ca marche pas
mais le comme let's go si je me suis je
me parle
givenchy je pense trop proches amis
émotions je devrais poule mais aussi des
faux scoop je le sens pau le sap au
filet
mais qui
arrive tout défaut que dis je le sais
repos pendant tu dis ah ça marche poppys
à m'entraîner street a ouvert en baisse
a même un moment donné à l'entraînement
le dans la belge en est peu changée
puisque j'étais comme c'est trop dur
artisitique allez je me suis genre
discret garde je vais devoir le faire
pareil ouais ça serait tout un cas ce
genre est des chiots ligue celtique les
cinq hommes switch gbc d'une seconde de
séquences où commencer ouais mais c'est
bien le mental dans les courses et tout
parce que tu peux pas contrôler ce qui
tu fais pas affecté tu peux je peux pas
contrôler à lakota quatrième jeu pour
contrer la cause des autres peut juste
contrôler ce que toi tu fais ce que je
sais c'est difficile parce que
maintenant moi je vais me parler et m'a
t-on dans un 200 m le java tout l'effet
partie repas sont bonnes au 100 libre je
peux bugs moi ma force c'est le come
back mais qui mêlait c'est dur
mentalement j'y vois toutes les ficelles
et le relais ces démonstrations de skate
en arrière de thé ma force et le camaq
je veux revenir métier d pas paniquer
puis de over swim pour essayer de rester
avec eux puis apprécier moi ça me coûte
ouais mais s'il faut commencer par lucie
dans une course en fonction des sommes
que le 20 sinon on se connaît tellement
qui est moi je sais que si je peux en
avant des lacs sans moi ça va pas besoin
de moi parce que je sais que je finis
par type et en même temps quelque peu
non mais c'est fou on entend du site et
des fois on me fait des entraînements on
va être point ensemble mettons moi je
partirai eux est là va partir dans une
autre corde aux chevaux ont fait 28
comme ps 28 28 amandine notre coach il
m'a coûté 27 ans qu'est ce qui
d'ailleurs est à côté de moi c'est pas
parce que subitement on est plus en chef
c'est tellement mental
j'écoutais un peu de gaz c'est 8 frôle
chez
soi que tout genre de personne qui a
reçu la meilleure athlète de hull 3 ans
durant avec de béton des 10 des 160 km
en montagne
puis tu l'as fait la fai a fait jal a
fait des compétitions a fait jusqu'à des
200 miles à 200 miles et 320 km qui a
fait des objets a fini avant les gueules
c'est vraiment trop forte puis
perso il essaie de comprendre qu'est ce
qui se passe dans ta tête
mais c'est ce qu'a dit sûr que health
cadix et
je fais juste me dire tout le temps
qu'ils ont aucune
aucun des états d'esprit use ou et
physique qui pour toujours fait que
jamais ton amer va sentir super bien
avec good pose pas trop parce que
sapin dans notre domaine des voix sens
comme un taux de marbre pendant la même
course le plus a
dit à son corps arrête pop il plaint toi
pas parce que ça va revenir si c'est
temporaire placé tout c'est mou de la
plus radicale a réussi avec en prenant
maintenant sa course à appliquer ça de
façon plus macro à sa vie au complète
brady béton il ya aucun moment dur qui
est éternel autant qu' aucun moment haye
qui est éternel fait qu'à chaque fois à
l'essai de tempérer un peu ses affaires
pour tout le temps comme continue
département jusqu'à mantes et
mentalement à la base j'ai l'impression
qu'il faut que tu conditionne son esprit
actuel au début a dit quant à lui des
moments où est-ce qu'elle est juste
arrêté en pleine rue d'une course parce
que le secret des cartes à la fois
d'après à le continuer plein la vue dans
mes hockey / sort du sort du trou a mené
par ce que tu viens déjà de prendre à
bord le labo assemble des surplus
d'énergie qui retirent mais on va le
conditionnement le pied on n'a pas
relayé des coaches qui sont tellement
bons pour faire croire à leurs athlètes
qui sont les meilleurs mets ton plus d'y
croire parce que oui sont les meilleurs
mais il ya des cochons je regarde
certains coja fait qu on connait le pc
comme avant leur course c'est comme un
des meilleurs je n'ai jamais vu autant
tpiy qui les conditionnent ap c'est fou
comme ça fait une différence c'est fou
pour mettant mon ex aucun rapport on est
en fait la voix
qui font
dix à tout le monde genre toutes les
cotes dit à tout le monde m'a privé
genre tout autre en finale puis genre
chanteur de ballades irlandaises en
mettant ces postes du coude parce que tu
es
sauf quelques mois sacré
avec tout le monde embarque fustigeant
ce disant georges meyer ici puis jean
par une listed performant pilote
finalement à manille
t'avais dit que tu allais me suivre dans
ma carrière telle est ma
télé
m'éviter en première partie de la
tournée une bière
mes médecins pour zouker mais c'est sûr
quelqu'un tu embarques
substitut derrière le bloc 4 continents
disant je prêche meilleur plusieurs la
paroisse de ma vie c'est sur la première
tant que quand tu es au foot khelil je
pense que ça va se passer mais j'ai
quelque chose à te soucies lycos le et
j'avais déjà su mais maintenant que je
sais maintenant je suis dans laquelle
j'ai plus confiance aux couches mais je
sais que lycos qualité peut arriver
quand les cas les confessions arrivera
plus tard
parce que kata s'en prennent à pied à
côté battu souvent on était en mai tout
était parti s'y met lui continue à faire
ce puits s'entraîner juste à côté nous
autres des fois c'est comme tu entends
juste les temps qui colle le togo au 54
fly qui fait ce genre 27,0 le sentir
rien à personne les mairies et jean
rouch wimpy je fais ce genre 33 bis ce
gars là vient pas de
56-18 hachey croate à barbe je suis le
seul à aimer ça marche ça marche et vous
mettant des beaux-arts pour que je pense
des plus voter
je veux pas ça fait mal d'années
habite le chien dans la finale puis mon
coach claude il me donnait un peu mon
âge que
le feeling
[Rires]
rappelle la folie un
autre groupe à côté faisait des peines
qui avaient on faisait tous dépasse le
meilleur coach de l'autre groupe à côté
qui parle à ses nageurs qui dit qu'ils
font kit des meilleures techniques si
c'est le meilleur que j'aie jamais vue
était tellement avais tu nous la
côtoyons
mac os 10 5 avril continue joe dante est
à nous si dubaï et un sens plus vite
qu'eux n'ont jamais vu à l'égard des
annonces est fou que c'était un
mois complet je vais jamais que mon
coach écrivain jacques carette dans les
warm up quand j'ai mon éternel mais en
fait moi je vais jamais dans les
piscines est compris j'aime pas ce jeu
pas que le monde veut voir dans le
basculement
des voix ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
est au contraire
mais je voulais pas flasher tu veux
flashé à regarder deux
tellement extraverti petit jeu la fille
dans le caniveau qui se sent l'énergie
et et je connais la plupart des nageurs
pas ce que je fais tout en parle à tout
le monde puis je peux genetec
dérange pour doter le monde vont se
taper ou un rêveur vas-y
effectué je prends juste à la légère way
fait coincer sur moi je me suis vite
pour montrer que
gardez-vous
et
puis là
avec les olympiques fini 4e tu pensais
que c'était ce que
parce que l'oeil à l' asm international
swimming league tout à fait la dernière
saison s'il fait les deux dernières tout
talent est entraînée avec les logis
stand-up zoodyssée en turquie
délai si c'est dans le fond ceux qui
nous écoutent c'est une nouvelle ligue
professionnelle de natation ou est-ce qu
il ya plusieurs équipes qui ont des
nageurs sur contre exactement dans le
fond je peux comparer c'est à une ligue
professionnelle de hockey gens là
ne sont pas les mêmes mais c'est le même
concept
exactement fait que d'enfants pour les
gens qui se déroule en passant comme
c'est du jargon pour moi c'est comme une
ligue professionnelle de la passion
commune autres sites professionnels les
professionnels allemands et qui a comme
une vie et vous et l'es6 et l'enfance il
ya dix équipes chaque équipe est basée
dans une ville différente dans le fond
catherine à le signer avec carrick en
dordogne l'équipe est basée en
californie puis moi je suis avec énergie
standard qui est basé à paris
ça ne veut pas nécessairement dire qu'
on s'entraîne avec eux avec l'équipe à
temps plein d'enfants elle la vit pas en
californie je suis pas paris mais dans
le fond pendant neuf saisons toutes les
athlètes de chaque équipe vont voyager
ensemble pour les compétitions pour les
marchés est ce que parce que là n'est
pas raciste dans une bulle ouais c'est
un petit peu différent à cause l'accueil
mais le est-ce que ça revient et lens
avant un mood fait goyer sèchement et
familiale - dans le fond si c'est le
concept change un tout petit peu parce
que c'est ça justement il ya encore la
queue vide mais c'est un peu moins
présent présentement donc une saison
régulière je peux la dre comme ceux et
se déroule pendant tout le mois de
septembre
puis c'est en italie on a quatre matches
chaque équipe mais on affronte les
équipes et chaque femme se meurt chaque
fin de semaine mais on n'est pas tout le
temps ensemble comme nous on s'affronte
mêmes poses
les plus fortes chances qu'on lui fait
qu'ils s'affrontent peu mais est il ya
une journée qu'on affronte en fait ces
quatre équipes par match et on échange
double des points le clip sera en demi
finale demi-finale qui va être en avons
encore pour un autre mot en neuf ans je
savais où est mon entendu que c'était ni
de linz mais amsterdam on essaie encore
de saumon n'ai pas vu ce n'est juste
entendu des pourparlers se dalphond
quand c'est arrivé le mouvement rappelle
alors sont arrivés avec ce kit une ligue
semi professionnelle mais aussi privés
c'est pas comme ces financiers
n'ont dit si l'on appelle fine on dit
aux nageurs si vous participez à la srv
peut pas participer aux épreuves finales
ouais ils n'auront fait six morts fuck
you espèces
oubliées ces
tests est nécessaire en natation parce
que tu es si on recense en perspective
je trouve que leur passion un peu
beaucoup médiatisé dans la vie de tous
les jours puis je pense pas que les gens
aient en général sont leurs demandes
dans la rue et canada où nos mémoires
que ken ash ra par michael phelps
dont le salue d'ailleurs pas un mauvais
gars
perspectives aux jeux olympiques la
natation c'est le deuxième soir le plus
regardé
mettez ça fait pas le lien les gens sont
pas comme hey mais notre je trouve que à
la télévision c.é mais c'est juste
médiatiser une fois en quatre ans puis
pourtant si les deux un sport le plus
regardé l'école premier dessus
c'est drôle pareil que ça département
des sports comme les sports comme le
secret des canalisations des
professionnels sont pas là
mais c'est c'est fake moi je trouve
qu'il ya un
potentiel
oui et du potentiel puis je pense que
c'est bien l'exploiter puis je pense que
c'était ce qu'on avait besoin dans mon
attention pour avoir plus d'expo d'expo
en expo chaud s'il sait qu'on fait nos
téléphones
vendus
une perspective mais absolument une
compétition de natation saturait 5 cl
clp
à l'huile de ces sept là on arrive à y
est celle où est ce que ces deux heures
on appellera dépasser n'est rien et donc
son taux relais on a moins le temps de
le lire
c'est tout pour l'équipe en fait
ouais ouais c'est ça qui me mets ton ok
c'est quoi le fonctionnement du hamas
une compétition est dans le fond si un
match va durer deux jours avec d'enfants
qui va s'étaler sur deux jours mais où
est ce que ces deux heures par jour donc
si vraiment ouais c'est d'afficher les
deux équipes
ouais deux jours après il ya huit
corridors dans une piscine il y en a
deux corridors parfait et qu'il y ait un
maximum de nageurs par geek faire les
préfectures une vague une vague du nez
profit une vague d'une épreuve garçons
évident at il dit y'a pas préliminaire
finalement vite sinon je vais dont je
mange peu vite mais c'est le hockey
ouais puis le lion rajouter l'année
passée je me rappelle de il ya vu un
article de sortie ou est-ce que tu
parlais un peu contre cette règle a pas
ce que c'est mais la règle c'était là
hostoak le premier touche il ya un temps
en pourcentage du temps qui est allouée
aux autres nageurs pour arriver aux
mains sinon ils se font voler leur point
par le premier leur font faire des bois
ton équipe ton équipe tu détestes ouais
mais moi j'ai acheté un petit peu contre
cette règle parce que de base et slt la
presse l on commente on se lavait fait
vendre supposer c'est comme si c'était
de rendre la natation accessible peu
juste au meilleur parce que ce qu'elle
se veut pas que toutes les meilleures
s'enrichissaient puis nous on tourne
avec l'onmt et on avait de la misère à
consonance chaque saison à ati puis tsl
a mené ces facteurs de high tech pour
faire ça de ma vie même si je suis poète
chad le clos un confrère obtient saran
des lamentations plus accessible donc
c'est vraiment de quoi d'intéressant
plomb on a une saison 2 plus les
meilleurs au monde s'ils sont trop vite
level ton argent - tony veulent ce
qu'ils veulent l argent sur 100 m compte
quelque chose à faire mais c'est pas
l'argent les points ou littéralement
l'argent littéralement l'argent et les
points les points
des points ton équipe tu deviens de
l'argent et des salades de bastia
précieuse mettons nos tu dois à parler
de tout parce que monsieur ou faut en
parler
ouais c'est quoi les salaires de base
pour mater saison pour cette année ses
saisons
1 c'est une saison 3 mois ouais c'est
d'e-mails pour tous les athlètes
par épreuve que tu fais est fait gagner
plus je pense qui si ton équipe sera
jusqu'en finale tu peux gagner plus ici
mercialys et les mettons par point le
tuer ou par e c'est une bonne question
et c'est sale l'année dernière ses
terres je pense le gagnant on faisait
800 par apple
sait déjà qu'on laisse ma place que
c'est ah non mais c'est sûr mettez les
gens sont quand même c'est tellement
beau coup et tout mais si on met sans
perspective non mais si le goy qui berce
au choix dans la ligue 2 est cool c'est
quand même un million
ces camions sortis le récemment change
de sujet on revient de relever ses
camions sortis les les salles l'argent
qui va qui va avec les médailles s'est
en sorti pilon une médaille d'or au
canada ça vous va mieux ça vaut genre
cent mille 1 millions et qui paieront
plus longtemps que moi mais vie mais si
beaucoup mais ce qu'on a travaillé faut
qu'une vingt et un jours seuls
les gens les gens qui ont pris toutes
les pcu est en fait plus d'argent que
quelqu'un qui a une gagnée médaille de
bronze pour le calembour vingt et un
entraînement les pneus n'ont rien gagné
pendant le méchant perspective le mois
sam brisé le coeur si j'ai pas une
médaille peu importe mais pour un thé
savoir le nombre d'années que tu
t'entraînes puis le nombre de sa crise
que tu fais c'est à dire que quelqu'un
puisse et je comprends que c'est passé
puis il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
avaient des besoins mais je pense que ce
n'est pas nécessairement adaptés pour
tous les gens pensent que
ces deux sujets
si la natation mais non même si on
arrive et on arrêtait notre job academy
on avait quand même rien mais
c'est un autre sujet comme tizimi bon
c'est ça parce que tu mets ton mot la
rémunération pour les sports amateurs
sont ceux qu'on les maîtres d'école sont
ces gens
là on a même déjà on avait parlé je
t'avais inquiet mais comme lisa qui va
ici trémousse
j'ai fait et j'ai fait de l'accord du
québec j'ai vu un chacun 50 piastres
c'est un piège à fin de ma carrière 50
pièces définissez comme arrêté puis
j'avais aucun financement de rien
d'autre le type c'est comme si tu t'en
tabarnak
pour ceux que ça prend des initiatives
comme cette ligue le
sport
match dehors qui est de la musique et
des justement un système de points que
cela comprend que
3.5 qui rendent les gens intéressés
exact c'est le jouet ce qu'ils ont voté
à écouter autant natation c'était de
cette ligue le agenda dsk qui nie si
jamais ça arrive mais peut-être que je
serai payé 1 million la team et moi
c'est le reste à dire s3pi lieu mais
c'est triste à dire mais ça revient au
final tout le terrain à l'offre la
demande puis aux acteurs publics et
privés
puis après ce si c'est possible avancer
collectivement comment qu'on veut encore
aux athlètes mettons en tant que société
comment qu'on veut donner pour nous avec
la gang cotisé pau puis moi je pense
qu'on pourrait donner un plus parce
qu'après ce justement ces désignations
d'argent c'est tellement délicat métier
je propose justement utiliser les impies
que ça fait tellement rêver pour juste
ceux qui participent au suspense juste
qu'ils sont des athlètes tout le monde
tout le monde qu'ils écoutent sarr
journée du monde et c'est ma mère était
pas aux jeunes mois voilà mes amis j'ai
des qualités on dirait que l'ambiance à
montréal tout le monde était plus
heureux tout le monde parlait de sport
même si les gens faisaient pas
nécessairement du sport ils suivaient
ceux qui étaient sais vraiment pas si
vite et si c'est des histoires autour
des années paix qui les lie d'études et
des belles histoires qui sortent de
l'oeil et toujours des moments qu'on
souligne marc pis les gens justement
c'est ça la marque paco et puis les gens
sont fiers des athlètes canadiens qui
voient pu puis sa tâche mais c'est après
ça il faut aussi vouloir collectivement
les encourager pour qu'ils puissent se
rendre le plus d'avoir plus et pour qui
plus est et fait que pâques c'est clair
qu'on pourrait décider en garde qui est
à quai au lieu de dix mille par année
que vous faites on leur donne 30 le très
frais de ses appartements à petite
échelle aussi le gisti on regarde tous
les sports ou québec est déjà un site
est parfait
il ya beaucoup d'effets non à mon pays
si on regarde la natation juste la
natation malheureusement on a de la
misère
c'est aussi ce 5e nul et même au canada
et une copie au québec non on rencontre
la fédé l'année la semaine prochaine
aidez-la
arrêtez de couper le financement aux
jeunes qui ont après 17 ans mais avec
des
choses
qu'on voulait discuter sécurité
permettant équipes du québec le sait
c'est rendu que tout le monde se voir
l'abc n'y fait qu'un t-shirt québec la
personne tout le monde en a ça en est si
tu fais un quelque chose qui est
vraiment comment un rêve pour les plus
jeunes qui comme fois l'équipe du québec
mais qui en est juste 10 au québec en
impôts et
production
c'est comme si ça devient un rail sa
fille parce qu'il ya un fou qui ne
citaient pandore est au québec fera rien
et puis aller aux jeux olympiques mais
il n'y a pas d'étapes un youri un fax
etc sont là ça me garde de faire les
jeux olympiques c'est démotivant syfy il
faudrait dix types un peu plus petit que
moi ça pas vraiment de le cas le simple
aux préjudices canada ensemble moi je
trouve excellent temps qu'on lui fait
c'est ça qu'elle soit qui les fasse
devant
l'équipe du québec pour les jeux du
canada bst socialiste est pas dans les
eaux les pays
l'ayant n'est plus très sûr je pense que
ça se voit là une adaptation québec
malheureusement
les bonnes années sont derrière nous non
mais ça
vous fait la leçon que vous êtes sur
l'équipe nationale ce que vous avez
votre collègue canada aussi où ils
disent non et
en théorie oui effectifs ça s'accumule
quand même le thé pour pourra être
capable de
s'adapter qu'avec le souffle que si
c'est quand même vraiment ici ça devient
avenue pour quand m ouais un athlète sur
le long terme à ma demande pas ce que je
vais faire un teint ouais c'est ça la
saison sauf que ça vaut pas la peine de
continuer encore
la saison cette nouvelle règle a ses
atouts combien de temps en temps mais
dans le fond la finale va se dérouler en
janvier je pensais les 7,8 j'en ai qu
est-ce qu au travers dans le fond tu
fais des compétitions de soupe des
compétitions aussi que se bat presque
tous
restés au pays après ouais on revient
mais ça m'est encore incertain en
parents et moi on revient trois semaines
encore un mois on revient trop à ce
n'était pas que ces prêts soient pas les
compétitions en tout genre les
championnats par équipes je sais pas le
8e canton et portant
des 100 m des championnats du monde est
ce qu'on va être choisie je sais pas
mais peut-être que ce serait un objectif
mais à force je sais pas si ça va
dépendre écoute mais vous entraîner une
semaine jusqu'au petit cadeau tu penses
tu que c'est quoi toi ton ful la
natation
catherine et
moi aussi je m'étais moi si je me
classais pas pour les jeux des jeux
c'était que fini tes l'oeil à sec s'est
rajouté you lie et celle qui s'est
rajouté je suis vraiment vraiment
vraiment content de vivre ce au moins
une fois dans ma vie tu es avant de
prendre ma retraite le sam on avait
tellement parlé
je suis vraiment content de le vivre une
fois le jeu en espérant que mon équipe
se rend jusqu'en janvier je vais
jusqu'au moins jusqu'en janvier et après
ça j si on me le demande tellement les
médias me demande ma famille mais le
démon s'en fout sinon j'ai encore
grecque est ce qui fait au total en 2010
46 non j'ai encore vu ce que ça me
mettrait mal impression à moi même genre
de décider quelque chose du genre fait
danser ses proches ne pas décider j'ai
pas envie de décider parce que tu es
sich pkp si je peux garder faire unique
et national
j'aurais pu de rêve là dedans je veux
dire ça sera plus accessible ça servira
pas à rien car hier mme en parlant que
je continue à nager
mais si je suis capable encore dit les
gens diront ce qu'ils voudront mais j'ai
quand même est très simple pensée pour
les jeux
nationale pour une coupe de donner
encore chez moi mais là
je suis là je sais pas qui c'est passé
sur l'orgueil de voir que des jeunes à
côté d'eux les quatorze halles dans
l'équipe
mais en même temps je regarde partout
dans le monde six jeunes de cet âge on
ne touche pas la plus vieille même titre
les
instruments annoncé deux journées si
j'ai de la misère à l'accepter moi même
si je la misère est je pense que ces
grands prix difficiles au canada parce
que je mets quand j'étais au juste
comment doit-on 2018 je n'ai jamais
j'avais 18 ans encore pis on se plie
telle équipe en deux je te dois en
partie plus vieille eau à 18 ans du fou
mais je sais qu'il ya eu un arrêt d
abord parce qu il ya eu la réforme parce
que le sait en sentant et penny les elle
toute seule ils vont avoir bon 26,6 en
2024 apprécie-t-il vont ils vont
vieillir avec mais c'est ce qu'il ya eu
tellement la réforme tort que l'oeil
sont en train de monter les jeunes mais
ces jeunes là ils vont continuer qui
vont avoir mon âge éventuellement le tir
elle l'astreint à précieux aux élèves
retière avants n'ont jamais dit que
j'étais heureux mais c'est juste que
l'eau en ce moment l'étape entre les
deux le mois versus les 14 heures une
fois que nous aurons à accepter jauger
de la misère je sais que je m'en fous
parce que tu es comme condition un autre
registre un numéro sur un
numéro un ce que
3,4 sport maintenant
non mais je sais pas tpiy mais
est-ce que théoriquement il ya un âge
idéal matthew surnage pays d'origine de
plus en plus des vieux des choses et on
voit le ti et au 50 libre le gagner sa
première médaille olympique à 35 ans
si ça prend bien mais ne l'ont
pas qu'il y en a d'autres qui en est
comme des samu qui en quatorze hommes
qui arrivent quatrièmes à carnot dans de
plus en plus vieux les plus en plus
jeunes puis comme il y en eu de
l'échec qui change les pays s'il y en a
autant qu'ils gagnent de lituanie que
les l'argentine que de l'australie
sasso vraiment
j'ai l'impression de choc la fourchette
est plus large qu'en pense le soutenait
suffit justement de continuer
d'encourager les athlètes passent un
certain georges qui est toujours tes
paupières fois brillé tout et il est
toujours possibilité de performer après
ikopa 17 ha parce que supposément ont
fait pas des meilleures terres mais on
est quand même le meilleur
canadien en théorie c'est une même le
site en outre 50 et il faut attendre
pour cent de ton temps mais ces anciens
votre avis oui mais
j'aurais by me l'enlèverez que cela peut
revenir en plus tu mets ton tu regardes
le dans plein d'autres sports sur garde
du monde qui qui mettons des dix
athlètes comme
qui sont pas de racheter maintenant dans
l'heure qui mettons de sauvegarde en
ligue nationale de hockey c'est
peut-être qu'ils sont pas de réfuter
plei son jardin ligues mineures plat
mené up il arrive dans la ligue
nationale genre 31,1 pisson sur le
deuxième trio puis sont bien fort c'est
ben correct c'est comme ça arrive le
discours de m
c'est à 17 ans et sont obligés d'arrêter
de manger pour commencer à travailler
pour se payer des à force elle avait
passé sept ans et plus et il était
vraiment besoin de plus de sport
j'avais mon trading à 13 ans la première
fois
j'habite chez ma mère
j'ai apprécié c'est à 22 ans où est ce
que je sais pour chaumont coddington
aussi je te mets dépenses à payer les
bars mais si cette ici c'est un besoin
je sais je sais ça c'est plus 18 ans
quand il est chez tes parents quant à
leur nature exacte des dépenses
légèrement la vision anti
les gens pensent à ce que beaucoup de
gens qui pensent que vous êtes riche
gens aussi qui pensent qu'on fait
absolument rien oui c'est jean
georges et permettant à domicile est
venu nestea gros chèque à kaboul
gimont coding va quasiment juste
associés fait un chèque de 18 mille
dollars à kaboul si je devais tout en
2016 type simitis et me cimon a retissé
page arts et
métiers
montrer à quel point c'est la réalité
on fait surtout ça parce qu'on aime ça
mais pour l'oreille
par rapport aux crues pythie depuis par
rapport aussi à l'intérêt que les gens
portent à ce sport le titre le dit aussi
tantôt à chaque quatre ans la tension
c'est comme on l'écouté on adore ce qui
existe c'est fois d'écouter la dation
paraît et et puis c'est encore plus fort
avec des athlètes que les gens
connaissent oui mais aussi avec des
systèmes comme les camps fermés mais
après ce pendant trois ans on en entend
c'est un désert total c'est chaud que si
on présentait la nation au monde sait
les intéresserait puis
s'est hissée comme à chaque achat de
quatre ans et comme dédé des héros
trois ans et demi c'est comme en donnant
à faire les jt mathis si on attendait
plus va parler c'est ce que nous allons
publier des jeunes qui est que tu
puisses y remet ça le foot est le sport
favori
ça donne un bon la motivation à tout le
monde le sait ça découle partout mais ça
peut peut-être comme ça c'est sûr que ça
aiderait le sport ça
titille après chacun olympique quelques
mois après il sort des statistiques de
riz beaucoup d'inscriptions les
inscriptions dans tel sport le disais
j'ai assisté à un quotidien une tête qui
représente 5 ans se sont brisées c'est
comme la
natation a augmenté en 2006 avec mais
comme la méthode et la fois comme
l'haltérophilie avec motorola gagnait
médaille d'or le langage qu en décembre
vont sortir 17,6
alors c'est cool sommes évidemment ça
devrait marcher c'est comme si la coste
alito quatre heures
exactes segmentation et aux quatre ans
la place je le fais martelé à tout là
toutes les armes et à capoue tous les ex
davut les inscriptions ou ok mais pas
puis malgré confinement au dessus des
parts et aux olympiques
y
[Rires]
avait des
cheveux dans le parc
à dubaï de
distancer le parc parc un mariage ça
demain oui cela répondrait
il y avait beaucoup de monde qui compte
6 points qui compétitionnait encore fait
que les personnes qui resteront les
buildings le respect ni sa tablette en
temps normal vous a rien dans les
premières semaines d'arrêt est restée
toute l'eau semaine d'après en mode
on suit les impôts dgi lâche sa
visite la ville
l'accès
on décompresse way puis admettons que
quelqu'un aurait fait à tokyo un petit
parti dans sa chambre d'hôtel ce que ça
aurait été des années on entend y avait
du bruit je sais qu'elle et le staff
sont venus ils jorion on a ôté torsion
email pour ce genre etc respect pour les
autres cas précis je pense à l'arrêté
est factice ont assez qu'on est là
dessus il ya du taf partout puis je
pense pour le respect des iso mais pas
question de vivre de ces questions deux
comme c'est le cas dans la chambre à
côté qui s'en va faire la confession des
olympiques au lendemain c'est fini mais
vous aviez fini pour partie de vous
rappeler ouais c'est ce facteur je pense
que je vais même peu importe toutes les
adeptes salle allait de soi que s'ils
avaient quelque chose tu es dehors parce
qu'ils étaient c'est ça pour le respect
de notre mais qui pire
c'est que la pile et chillingo parc
non bailly poche chez points c'est juste
pour te brûler le stand by coûtait je
sais pas cette époque c'est pour faux
départ qu'est ce qu'on comprend c'est
que c'est pas du groupe ares qui s'est
passé ce n'est pas dès cette époque où
il y avait peu de la musique qui te dit
si un club le test aujourd'hui contador
on était assis et attendre des genres et
de montille ans en jugeant si tôt
est-ce que vous avez quand même pu
socialiser avec m dix athlètes d'autres
ports du pays foyen way coût
[Rires]
5 ans va y est on avait notre masque ou
peu importe mais souvent la méthode la
plus facile pour les booster à café
vous avez vous un genre de blues dans
deux postes la scène s'est
passée
après l'expérience faisant tomber
je peux faire un bon jour juste une
chimie nous
je pense deux jours après à teri hatcher
top parti de l'abeille à l'adresse est
chez nous et en plus ça faisait comme
justement ça fait plus qu'un mot qu'on
était way s'est littéralement gens m'ont
dit qu'elles sont liées ces pigeons
c'est se tait on était attirée à tibi
avec quelqu'un plein la machine check
michaud
est ce que tu veux
pas tant que
message à verdun mais
ouais mais c'est un endroit qui est moi
je prend corps sur le petit nuage
fait fondre et je n'ai pas encore
réalisé je te dirai c'est pas tout le
monde qui dit pas mais je devrais
probablement qui est à paris si tout va
bien on va toucher du bois mais je vais
prendre à moi plus le ressenti du blues
après les communes aux
images histoire après 10 heures après
les comme un droit parce que c'était
fini
[Rires]
mais c'est ce même temps elle a dit
c'est ça mais pour le rêve d'une vie
ces cas et c'est fait
c'est quoi la prochaine étape
je pense que cassandra baby pleut mais
est-ce que vous pensez que vous projeter
dans l'avenir loin et m'attendre est ce
que vous imaginez ça va être que votre
vie maintenant dans les temps
comment
[Rires]
expliquer ce que je fais à dans le
film je bois et et de mes amis de kiki
et qui en lisant enfin et puis on te
suit juste comme je reviens d'isoler les
pics jusqu'à acheter
par le tatami si c'est mesquin médian
des maisons il ya des six mois on me
demande où je vais vivre la semaine
prochaine
jusqu'au
tombeau pole
[Rires]
mais fait que la techno la pensée non
non quoi
c'est
cela qui me fait le plus plaisir qu'un
dû penser quoi le ton
sur ton souvent où je vous ne m'écoutez
c'est dans un avenir rapproché on
parlera pas de vin et amples sur le vin
est assez vite
si vieux j'avais des crampes
non mais tu en es si je veux je veux je
vais voyager comme ma carrière de
natation est fini mais je pense
[Musique]
que
j'ai un diplôme d'enseignement je sais
pas 100% si je vais enseigner à 100%
mais j'ai ce
service et mario est arrivé ça déjà j'ai
des
wannabe
impression il est intime et ont voyagé
de cette impression que
tu veux faire les expériences que met-on
torre voulu faire mais qui t'empêche et
paco natation vtt voyage et arts et
métiers maintenant par simone back pack
propose de capter un tas dit j'ai quand
même déjà fait partir avec moi encore
en 2010 j'ai arrêté puis je tripe j'aime
ce
match une personne qui s'ennuient je me
pose pas ce qu'ils m'appellent maman je
ne voulais pas mais non je ne sais pas
mais match pas qu'ils savent eux george
mc vivre d'autre chose
vivre des choses c'est que jamais jamais
vraiment chez vous c'est parce que j'ai
pas de vie stable à l'inquiéter la
journaliste d'abc g10 enfance jusqu'à
c'était peut-être que je vais me poser
plus mais en ce moment c'est possible ce
n'est seulement que j'ai envie de vivre
non plus dans un avenir rapproché faut
que tu vas faire soupire puis après son
verrou j'ai toujours partie du voyage et
wav et s'il passe le premier souci
bassiste que julie on sait jamais le mot
je pensais pas être encore là en ce
moment et dans la piscine et que j'étais
fatigué tellement de choses qui changent
et je sais pas été à toutes les fois je
vois mon paille comme lust venir vivre à
fond rouge
je sais pas
qui c'est toi tellement que j'ai avec
mes mais oui je sais pas mais oui ouais
mais tu ferais quoi committed ben c'est
ça la clé j'ai conscience à ce qu'en
janvier de design graphique que je
mangeais leur sport et je vais pas
danger universitaire ah ouais
mais je pense que c'est parce qu'on a un
gros creux au québec il ya un creux
quand même un sens puis baisser le feu
non un système on dirait qu'ils aient
déjà vers rencontré un entraîneur
des universités puis mais elle avait pas
tant vendu le type est autiste on traîne
moi j'ai fait tout ce que j'avais à
faire piller est pas mort on aussi métis
t'es pas les sentiments mais j'étais
vraiment ce que vous voulez
quand même si je vais m'entraîner fort
je veux bien faire puis si j'avais
besoin d'un entraîneur qui me donnent
des
noms c'est sûr mais juste les
commissions fun là d'un
gros
chèque émis par an il y aurait bien des
billets émis que je fasse bouger entre
parce que c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
rencontré son équipe dans la façon de
bouger
ok c'est soit qu'il y ait souvent
espérons qu'ils me disent tu aurais pu
un peu mais bon je me
rendis qu'il entraîne ma petite cousine
alors que le monde est et
ouest
c 'est je t'aiderai dans trois ans ça
serait paris puis appréciait j'aimerais
rentrer en architecture coucou ouais
c'est ça mais j'ai bien hâte de
commencer l'école face à temps plein
parce que je pense que je suis quelqu'un
qui veut s'investir à 100% dans quelque
chose de plus en plus de la misère à
faire moitié moitié puis c'est pour
l'instant je mets 10 ans ça s'est passé
paternel puis je sais qu'il me reste
quelques années donc j'essaie d'en
profiter le plus possible pour apprécier
pour me concentrer sur mes études puis
m'épanouir l'attend après ouais fait que
je pense que c'est ça me met plein dans
les prochaines années coût
nicky mode jet d'une enfant
ces cas là je vois vraiment sonnée même
le puits moi un peu moins pour quatre
parce que on est plus proche en ange b
pour toi je vois vraiment sonné comme le
vieux
le vieux qui donne des conseils mais
nigma et j'ai dit ce que j'avais à peu
près ton âge je l'avais pas écouté puis
à ce jour
j'aurais dû l'écouter
j'ai raté ma vie
il m'avait dit
les années que tu viens vite en vo
vivent le même temps les cinq prochaines
années il m'avait dit ça va être les
meilleures années de ta vie
puis profites en puis il m'avait dit sur
l'appui lui avait fait exactement le
même parcours que moi dans le fond est
lui aussi est allé à l'université a
commencé en littérature il a fait son
show hier le son université avait mangé
avec avait gagné les six a essayé même
parcours vraiment un
il m'avait dit ça m'avait dit pitié dire
il y avait les avais pensé qu'ils
étaient heureux
sauf qui maudit les cinq prochaines
années ça va être les meilleures années
ta vie ni rends toi compte parce que
parce que lui ce qui est dit c'est moi
je m'en suis pas rendu qu'on fait pas la
même erreur que moi le moi je l'écoutais
les fêtes phoque dhabi pas vrai ce que
tu dis fait que je vais pas être cassé
puis là moi je repasse le même message
que lui avait dit de dire profites en
crise parce que ça revient pas mais je
me rappelle qu'ils se mettent autant
pour nous
j'ose croire qu'ici tout le temps les
choses croit que les cinq prochaines
années sont pourtant les meilleurs de ta
vie maintenant
méthon sauf que
georges 5 un entraînement de partir en
gang pendant deux semaines en camp
d'entraînement
genre dans le sud à porto rico le fait
qu on le fait dans l'ensemble on a fait
un fleury de
chaillot
sari arrivera
jamais tu penses que tu es dans les
mêmes ici la fin vraiment que tu fais là
aller avec une gagne aucun entraînement
le poteau le téléphone c'est des fautes
des journées des tripes is it et de
défoncer la gueule d'un établissement je
dormais la face et te rappelle peut-être
50 ah non mais tu nous rassembles est
rappelle j des bons moments avec les
gens la journée où est ce que la journée
est finie tu te rappelles potes que tu
viens de payer comme un sale le petit
rappel chose que tu as payé avec tout le
monde plutôt un lien pour toujours
exigeant alex et moi tout tout mais
toutes mes amies natation avec qui je
talent camp d'entraînement toutes mes
amis d'université avec qui j'étais allé
et j'ai nagé pour le rouge et or tout ce
monde le sait pour toujours c'est pour
toujours puis surgit pas sûr que davie
sari arrive après mais ça va dans tout
les domaines en tant que tel qu'un tel
concentré ce quelque chose on dirait
qu'on en profite juste
c'est non pas une relation mais
n'importe qui qui fonctionne en
universitaire pour les jobs étudiants
utilisateurs et genre ça revienne un peu
éteinte à jobs lité comme serveur dans
un resto le pti mais si c'est je crois
pas être se revoir dans un réseau de ta
vie avec ce staff le tueur pas
travailler avec le monde paysan en kilos
né dans le rush de repas passe à travers
leurs ruches mais avec ce monde l'autre
tu vises moment le puits c'est facile
quand tu es dans le moment mettons en
natation puis puis d'envy mettons en
général même ton gars dont l'exemple à
la dation c'est quand un creux qui
trouve sur l'on retrouve la saison est
longue d'élastiques c'est de la marde ça
me tente plus crise de support de marbre
le cas quand tu prends la peine de faire
et je tellement privilégié de pouvoir me
défoncer le même pouvoir repousser mes
limites
on va voir finir l'entraînement piaggio
est d'avoir tout donné sortir la piscine
farah et là je viens d'être aujourd'hui
genre le je suis meilleur que veut le
2h20 qui est ce que ça vaut de l'or se
passe arrive pas tant que ça non ce qui
est dit est la phrase de niklas et la
même phrase des
candidats la finale 10 office project
racisme mais jaïdi
dit gérer mais c'est qu'il ya une façon
de savoir qui tu as dit que tu es dans
les gondoles 2 avant que le rôle des
pauvres et les petits lui profite ici
même si j'ai visionné oui c'est dans
tout mais le spectre de spécial du monde
à la fête du port jeunes quittent avoir
arrêté jeunes partent à l'université
j'ai tellement d'autres choses que j'ai
vécues dodge a des tripes d'odeurs de
trip de gang mais même à se haïr rien
comme ceux
qui poursuit la
lettre mais
le feeling d'une équipe de sport il faut
un peu l'avons véhicule c'est pour
compenser quoi raison laquelle ces
années j'ai des enfants ils vont faire
du sport c'est sûr y'a aucun passeport
aucune chance
savais que je me disais bonne valeur ça
apprend la discipline ça apprend le
dépassement de soi ça apprend de
abandonné qu'un cas ces 12 cas ça m'a
fait mal à tout les jours le tipi
joaquin hussein sens
oui pipi sur tout ce qui sera de plus en
plus loin ceux qui ont persévéré c'est
on a tout connu aussi des gens quitter
après ce choc qui sont bien heureux
qu'ils ont eu peur d'élever mes tickets
sont misérables
qu'eux à mener c'est
ce que le mental est peu suivie à vannes
et c'est juste c'est cindy qui est dur
la vie de d'athlètes de haut niveau le
tpiy la plus craquante et ceux qui
continuent comme vous jusqu'au bout
c'est êtes cet homme en quittant les
pays après disons pas le mental mais
tout le monde a un mental d'acier juste
pour se rendre lopy en fait le chemin
pour se rendre c'est ce fou lancé
mais
c'est ce petit pis
il ya quelque chose de boda
l'intensité absolue dans une affaire le
cpie petit bout chez quelqu'un qui prône
dans la vie de tous les jours
les kills et puis je reconnaissais
remontée pas besoin des jarrets
défoncé mais c'est semer pour quelque
chose de cool dans ce cadre qui pue trop
bas ce type i
ben oui absolument ne faudrait pas déjà
ils font partie de notre vie ont été
vidés fouad do
défaut dans d'autres sphères aussi de la
vie ça peut le moins 30 services que
dans le sport peut-être incité le métier
malines alcoolisme tu me une affaire qui
a contribué à mon succès mettons dans le
sport le bon succès modéré d'est et que
je déteste perdre et perdre c'était
quelque chose que je me décide ce qui
est comme ça dans ta vie manon mais oui
pis ça crée des problèmes
mais je me compare dans tout tout tout
jeudi le juge mange quand il mange plus
vite que la
lumière j'ai déconné
mais c'est grave c'est grave me demande
si comme indice normal le 15
mai huit modules communs c'est comme ça
il fallut cette intensité le
mississippi en bout de ligne c'est
autant qui était justement que
l'équilibré toutes les sphères de la vie
georges prendre ce que ce qu on se
souvient en bout de ligne c'est ce qui
était faux king john perse dans une
affaire qui va rater quelque chose qui
ont fait du côté de belgrade qui ce que
vous avez fait ici
y est
là mais si c'est parce qu'on a trouvé
plus à les regarder sur votre vie en
arrière à ce titre vous allez regarder
votre tatou qui à ce moment est facile
de par l'auteur n'a pas réussi ce thème
est embêtant pour nous parce que j'ai
peur parce que j'ai bien dit comme ça
mais c'est parce qu'il était un truc ça
fait tellement partie de notre quotidien
un terrain qu'on le voit on était en
plein aux as mais un pic puis on était
avec des gens comme usain bolt pigeon
c'est une équipe qui gagne tout fait
qu'ils sont vraiment vraiment les
meilleurs c'est tu es juste l'impression
d'être les moins bons des meilleurs
autant accès qu'à menus c'est que
compterait en réalisme quand c'est juste
parce que les bonis leone et aussi mes
choix raisons à cela si je trouve un des
gros problèmes de notre société c'est on
valorise beaucoup les gens par rapport à
la médaille c'est sur l'autre ce petit
je pense que oui c'est bien une médaille
mais la médaille ne fait pas la clé
parce que je pense que olympique le
problème c'est que dans l'oeil
médiatique tous les sports ont la même
valeur mettons le wi fi une médaille
mais dont
je veux dire quelque chose puis
je les ai tellement je n'ai pas
nécessairement peser mes mots parce que
c'est quelque chose que je crois
fondamentalement le mais je pense
qu'elle use olympique en natation c'est
probablement le sport le plus difficile
à se rendre aux olympiques quand tu
regardes le guerre mettons que gagner le
tir au pistolet la médaille d'or ça fait
cinq ans que commencer à tirer au
pistolet le tipi fait certes pas partir
dans le sous-sol de chez eux
nous allons essayer quand même le
meilleur dans son domaine c'est fake ou
amis d'enfance dans le sens celui qui
vaut aux olympiques pour le canada en
tirs au pistolet on s'entend que son jeu
parcours et des colis cement moins ardue
que le vôtre mais ton si on considère
que le gars qui gagne la médaille d'or
ça fait 50 tirs au pistolet le thé dans
un
effectif permettant pas par
l'entraînement choqué natation c'est un
des sports où est ce qu on doit
entraîner le plus
le nombre de fois que je t'ai ans par
l'étude ou secondaire puis j'avais les
cheveux mouillés parce que mon âge on a
commencé actuellement on était quelques
temps ce temps des fêtes les autres les
docteurs sport et en sport études mais
pourquoi tu manges l'après midi jusqu'à
moi mais je mange les matins au chili a
pris aux juges à sion il ya aussi
beaucoup plus de monde mais c'est son
nom est juste les bassins et l'alsace
est
totalement le sport qu'elle plus de
monde qui pratiquaient ici le tiff
inquiet c'est soit que juste en termes
statistiques et c'est plutôt fera route
côté look stylé avec mettons fait que
mes droits c'est l'ascétisme aussi
certaines épreuves le puisque d'autres
épreuves les trois personnes au québec
qui en font le mais mettons pour ce que
d'aller aux olympiques de juste aller
aux olympiques n'a pas la même valeur
selon le sport dans quelques petits mais
j'ai décidé de faire un article à petit
parce que ça me fait vraiment de la
peine à manille gb cette semaine j'ai vu
un commentaire d'une agente et sur une
athlète qui disait comme l'athlète
aurait mérité la médaille pour finir sa
carrière à la hauteur de ce qu'elle
était mais chacun à quel point
sa carrière le vicky type sa carrière à
mérite tout autant le respect je suis là
promis ça
m'a fait des quartz et qui on dirait
qu'il est justement c'est moi je les
véhicules revenir avec une médaille en
puis je les réalise et poti je réalisais
pas ce que savait comme impact sur les
autres
cgt au gt dont pierre d'avoir cette
médaille le thé mais là on dirait que le
jeu revient à l'opposé je reviens sans
médaille
comment
puis je me trouve pas moins est bonne et
puis je trouve ça à la limite tu risques
comment on valorise vraiment les
médailles psy c'est comme on fait le
décompte des médailles puis qui ont par
les médaillés d'or peut-être
mais crime genre petit une médaille dans
le fond lui ce rapport le premier parce
que c'est le client le gagnant et gangs
mais c'est tout les autres parcours ses
dépositions l'écologie décidé
d'attribuer la main la médaille d'or
qu'on n'a jamais vues avant buisson tout
bêtement parce que y ont performé le
moment où le vix est c'est le moment là
on n'a pas toutes le même mot malo le
toit mais on n'est pas moins bon pour
autant sinon c'est quoi je sais pas ça
m'a fait ça m'a fait de quoi de réaliser
ce pigeon
c'est certain on était trois cent
soixante dix athlètes je pense que les
jeunes
c'est sa pige à hautmont dit qu'on est
fier des médaillés d'or petit oui oui
oui on est fier
mais je pense qu'on a le droit d'être
fier de toutes les trois cent soixante
dix athlètes autres citic définitivement
puis je trouve qu'on valorise pas assez
c'est parce qu est encore là on parle de
l'élite des quelque chose l'élite des
athlètes reçues qui sont là sont des
élites dans leurs choix respectifs
et les temps tarmac dans certains sports
comme la natation du téléthon puisque à
suivre c'est quoi ce après les faits
étaient les dents tabarnak quand tu
veuilles des meilleures au pays
qu'est ce qu'on aurait fait différemment
dispense
comment ça peut être très bas meudon
mais je pense qu'ils étaient
premièrement connaître le parcours des
athlètes je pense des dépenses et
pertinents nous on est dans un monde
avec les athlètes moi je connais les
athlètes puis je connais même pas le
parcours de mes amis nécessairement team
puis je trouve que c'est des fois le
sait encore bien plus impressionnant le
parcours qu'ils ont vécu au sérieux
plutôt que dehors tu es arrivé de gagner
une médaille t'es je trouve que des gens
qui sont bien plus impressionnant de
leur parcours même si on jamais une
médaille dis moi je trouve honnêtement
mettons je parle justement parce que je
peux parler des autres maisons mais mon
parcours je trouve un plus
impressionnant que ma médaille de bronze
que j'ai gagné c'est là que je pense que
c'est le cas pour vraiment beaucoup
d'athlètes susurre on s'est même posé
comme mais s'il faut pas dire ça ça
relève que
l'ombre mais était comme ils y ont fait
des reportages un peu avant avoir les
jeux le radio can be a dit john abell
mettons je connais depuis longtemps et
je dis j'allais chez eux à toutes les
semaines si je faisais dix tireurs avec
avec l'enfant de david entre bref qui
j'ai écouté son reportage puisque après
si j'étais cheap chic alors je
connaissais pas cette partie de ta vie
puis j'ai aimé ça avoir siégé comme j'ai
appris des choses je souhaite c'est
tellement beau sont par copie il y en a
tellement les athlètes comme ce qu'on
sait peu c'est au final qui va les
rejoindre les gens chez eux c'est bien
de savoir rester après côté akouala la
personne qu'on garde qui dit bonne à
passer à travers le métier je pense que
les médias ne porte pas attention mais
pourtant moins étant petite fille
comprendre comment cette personne s'est
rendue aux olympiques et mon rêve dit
comprendre son parcours puis devant tout
qu'est-ce qu'on allait passer à travers
puis d'être inspiré par ce ça
m'inspirait plus à dire à qui était à
l'effet de ce ceux qui avaient pensé par
le pi ccb plus inspirants pour des
enfants qui allégeait non seulement
vers être plus loin sur ce qui marche
pas la seule à avoir des moments
difficiles puis c'est normal puis je
pense et de normaliser le to qui on
n'est pas invincible ce n'est pas tout
beau c'est pas tout vert
parce que les modèles des jeunes en ce
moment c'est ce qu'ils ont gagné
médaille d'or mettant second la médaille
du coup les écoles pillards ne la donne
qui sont pas si ce sont peu plus
impressionnant aussi payant ne le jeu
par leur large georges parle d'elle en
larmes et il y en eut que c'est même peu
des belles personnes genre je parle de
personnalités qui
alors que tu es comme étant témoin je te
connais je connais ton parcours était
quand même eu un article autrefois puis
j'ai vite embargo ça me fait quand même
de quoi tic moi parce que je les connais
puis je le connais son parcours t am
avait déjà raconté déchets terrain gelé
vic avec elle puis juste le fait de le
lire ça m'a fait de quoi parer et et je
pense que ça peut rejoindre même plus et
même plus accès ça montre bien plus que
genre si une personne normale que ouais
parce que je sais pas c'est si c'est
vrai t'as raison c'est pour ça
merci les filles d'abord parce qu'ils
bonne chance dans la ligue qui s'en
vient ensuite une bonne dans le forez où
vous allez vous rendre sur mais sûrement
jusqu'en
2006 oui en finale on n'est ce pas elle
son équipe allait gagner les deux usages
florent manaudou puis
les plus beaux couples m ont permis aux
blue
un
beauty shot de keith richards
des je t'aime et ses
propos en natation t sont tellement
beaux sont tellement faim puis câline
sont bons aussi la chine
toute école co50
ouais parce que parce que clairement les
manaudou ont déjà il me dit oui avec toi
ça va être ça va l'annoncer pic puis toi
tout avec calogero
peu dans la vie mais
qui est
celle que le tiers
des prêts cet aprem cosby et celle qui
venait de faire le record du monde en 58
ans et plus lui il déposait son stock
sur le bord de la piscine pour aller
faire que notre presse doit être
bourré
de tellement
j il devait avoir la caféine dans le
tape il passa y avait de l'énergie
mais même vous avez piqué finissait sa
course il nageait dans le bassin
longeant des big shot 4-3-3 de
personnes
j'avais vu quelqu'un d'aussi jack kirby
wii
[Musique]
ou que justement ça puisse c'est que que
cette règle existe pour sacrer des mix
de monde qui ne peuvent pas dans le fond
le message qu'attendaient les quelques
l'américain est ok mais aulas c'est
vraiment cool à danser et c'est ça
permet aussi de connaître des
compétiteurs des amitiés pas absolument
témoin juste une fois par année que dans
les grosses compétitions soit champion
du monde ou jusqu'au manoir aux jeux
olympiques petits voient une fois par
année dans le baby boom cela peut il pas
des biens mais le ce ça permet que t on
et pendant un mois le tout les athlètes
on est toutes ensemble 1 c'est ce qu'ils
font c'est qu'après sur le témoin je
peux aller ensuite puis je m'endors
s'arrache
suppléments et que ça crée des liens
c'est ce qu'ils font très cool travail
j'allais poser une autre question mais
il avait dû connaître j'allais me disent
j'ai demandé c'était quoi là il y avait
eu un bon feeling d'equipe canada a
commencé
comment ça marche
encore partir c'est
le canada aux jeux du canada étant le
canada 2 si tu le jettes une distinction
au québec
mais très honnêtement ça fait 12 ans que
je suis désolé mais je pense que c'est
grave l'équipe cette année où j'ai vu le
plus de séparation
oui j'aime explique dans son sous là on
était quoi 25 nageurs il y en a dix sept
qui sont à même cube qui arrive faisons
surtout une équipe a reçoit son iniquité
la spa qui arrivent les puits sont en
majorité qui sont imposables son loupé
c'est eux qui prennent les décisions
s'il leur coach qui co chief qui tout
est en fonction il ya la décision par
rapport au réel et par rapport à pisser
comme je disais tantôt tout les membres
de l'équipe de relais on est quoi il ya
combien de filles dans tout qui ont fait
des relais peut-être 13 me tend les bras
je sais comme ça mais on est on est on
est y était
et est ce que les décisions toujours
basé ce
nom est-ce qu'il était toujours là j'ai
par rapport au tac les enfants n'ont
fait que faire ça mais à peine de dire
qu'est ce qui t'a dit la première fois
genre favriel ouais ce que tu comptes l
autre fois sur l'option ne sais pas si
tu veux pas parler de ça mais en
fait que des enfants tout était classé
pour la 4e fois de la jemaye sera séparé
le matin ses cinquièmes jo après
l'humeur exactement puis ai fait le bien
contente de faire l'équipe et tous avec
quatre femmes ont plongé le 4 x 2 pilati
moi je m'entraîne pour ce samedi à
l'entraînement puis c'est quelque chose
que je rends compte pour nous deux c'est
comptait peu
dans l'oeil de mire de personnes mais on
a fait notre job bien à l'entraînement
ça paraissait contre on travaillait bien
vivement que tout les coachs l'ont vu
dit
dans le fond quand montarville la
journée laver la grande première journée
compétir - la veille la prochaine
compétition et si on est un meeting avec
un coach puis c'était moi 4 avant tout
les journaux dominicaux juste de 15
notamment puis le en gros il dit 4 voilà
quatre fois ça parce que tu risques
d'être fatigué qui mérite sa part faire
la carte 3 2 c'est la course que je
posais pas
si moi je m'entraîne depuis un mois je
fais juste du kroll pour cela tu es tu
allé au japon
l'afer qui pillay s'est lamenté moi
c'est sûr je me mets à pleurer la
colline noté simon riley un petit en
place dès que je me suis fait à l'idée
après les essais j'ai pas fait de
l'équipe tu m'amènes à tokyo peu après
c'est une dit que non je mérite ma place
fait clair moi j'ai demandé jeudi
pourquoi dis maman pourquoi vous m'avez
amenée ici qui la seule affaire qui m'a
dit c'est pas moi qui décide et
quelqu'un qui décide je les
sens la sélection s'est déclaré pour une
décision personnelle a le mérité sa
place
dans l'instance est effaré par un
entraîneur un qui l'aurait pas choisi je
sais pas ce que tu as fait à l'intérieur
mais cet effort tant sacrément parce que
les jours après la séquence et avait
brisé tout le monde ça le québec est
moche
avec des décisions politiques comme ça
mais
ça me jusqu'en millar a jamais mis en
crise le rejeter que je fait la job je
m'entraîne je mérite ma place puis j'ai
appris
la journée même si le matin et le soir 7
4 x 2 j'ai appris qu'il mettait dans le
relais
parce que tout français qui veulent te
l'avouer
on parle trop jours tout passe idéale
pour y
échanger mais il m'avait dit que je
faisais le dos dans le 4 x 100 m les
mecs qui va l'entraîner pour le 112 ch
et savait que ça allait bien à l'effet
que le moi c'était comme acquis prochain
objectif le ceja faire un bon temps au
100 dos pour leur prouver que je mérite
ma place dans le 4 x 100 quatre nages
que fille ouais c'était cela le système
adjoint la clé c'était business business
business les gens prient channel 4 x 2
puis j'ai fait mieux que ce qu'est ce
qu'ils pensaient un éclatement été
surpris c'est clément dans ma tête et
j'ai bien fait on va me récompenser par
me laisser monsanto mais finalement
récompensée par m'enlever le reste de
mes épreuves
mais c'est ce parce qu'il n'ya pas de
coach en
élisant nous sommes francophones tout
aussi c'est tout les leaf le coche le
lieu toutes ces filles qui veut gagner
médaille pour tous ses fils et un
fax il
en avait perçu ses mines en jeu réussie
il réussit toutes ces filles ont eu des
médailles
[Musique]
je pense que
si vous vous étiez pas il n'y a pas de
coach québec allait le bout
de leur coach
les phénomènes 16 autres chalets qui
inscrivent pas yannick lupien aux 50
crawl mais
les québécois ces équipes nationales
c'est pas la première histoire d'amour
tout l'esprit
comme le fait qu'on soit québécoises les
plus les conçoit juste pas dans la gang
dit quoi le népal
du coup
si vous étiez anglophone et dans l'ouest
vous seriez sûrement au sens national c
sa la pa c'est quand ils habitent ici je
fais je fais des jo qu'en disent les
anglos espace est pas la première fois
que des histoires comme ça québécois
francophones ça arrive sur des
équipements là c'est triste et en parler
à des athlètes
toujours votre coach a des potes on est
de faire un petit appel farley tabarnak
de carolis surmont canada que ce qui se
passe et d'autres discussions mais
ouais c'est pas lui qui aurait
le dernier mot
voilà maintenant je suis métiers des
fois maintenant justin bieber
a lieu mais celui-ci en regardant c'est
juste du sporting me consoler vous
préparer le mieux possible non pauvresse
hébété puisse aussi une femme et il ya
eu plein de sa fin comme ça puis qu'il
faut casser des fois c desservant des
désirs de ses ventes
surtout quand c'est politique c'est pas
baser ses performances étaient quelque
chose qui est déjà aux essais
avec
tact et si les affaires qui sont communs
juste un peu mais tj lizin une affaire
aussi un canot kayak canot kayak je
pense à ce que les x fait qu'empirer
pour une autre fille parce que y'en a
ticket sport ça devait arriver arrive
tout le temps parce que le coach d'un
coach de quelqu'un tue mais oui comme
chef d'un coach de quelqu'un tout le
temps pourcentage d'histoire de coups de
cochon qui se font en arrière de la cie
à l'arrière de la caméra et de navarre
plein que les gens le savent
comme ça on n'est jamais sûr on n'a
jamais su ce dont je me suis si c'était
pour le tous les journaux on va parler
de cinéma par l'osce en série par tous
les ans par les athlètes l'âme extrait
est coaché l'eau oscille somme à
l'ecosse entre le poète
élections par tous noirs étaient tous
d'ici peu et et on en a vu d affaires et
puis on a entendu des affaires pisser
peu sport compte de filmer ce type il a
été conçu pour une dernière que
j'arrêtais de coach et c'est ça parce
qu'il ya un mais c'est comme tu coches
le truc ton athlète fasse le mieux genre
tu veux mettre eux-mêmes que les autres
athlètes des autres coachs fasse le
mieux mais l'autre sans que les autres
coaches et comme ils l'auraient
hypothèse le raclette pire post les
tient qu'à cela mène je veux juste avoir
une place à part couloir pour le warm up
et non c'est mon boulot
on fait la même chose l'on veut toutes
les deux dans un même pays mais ça
paraît peu évident 8 vous sautez pas
comme une équipe u médian crédit dans le
médium du relais 4 x 100 m et 4 x 200 le
matin
n'était même pas une équipe
en tête 2 2 c'est comme c'est qui qui va
de mériter sa place pour la finale c'est
exactement et a confessé en lutte contre
ces même panier ouais taxi dommage c'est
vraiment dommage
la compétition t on alors parler
justement d'être compétitifs tant topix
a laissé pousser condé poser clairement
tu veut
le repousser les limites tout le temps
peut-être la meilleure possible mais
amener ces crises à faire de même de ces
puces sans moi ce serait beau c'est plus
notre puce à la beauté du sport c'est ce
que tente dans les médias calme et
c'était quand c'est tellement fait
parler a commencé c'est une belle équipe
de ce bail en amérique il ya les autres
ne s'était pas c'est plate parce que
qu'en savez l'une d'autres parce que dix
ans on avait les autres cités on avait
certaines personnes au cif accès
au soin de vous avoir encore longtemps
merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin de ce père que vous avez
apprécié les conversations ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de cas
si l'on vous remercie vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passe hier sur p tu
es a non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce qu
on les tourne donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs au monde pétulant
nous aussi quand on parle d'homme nicole
et moi de la conversation qu'ont bien
d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page rituels et le lien vers savoir dans
la description du podcast fait qu'il ya
merci encore une fois nous avons écouté
jusqu'à la fin